foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
or whatever still let me know and I do
need to do the whole uh if I was
disciples back so hit me we'll figure it
out hopefully before reset Lydia Master
what's up oh yeah
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
I'm being on a podcast next week I don't
know what they want me to say oh yeah
let's not dude let's not stitch
[Music]
oh shark in a chair I never see that
name what's going on
what's going on Donald Taco the homie
what's up five dollars with the chat
shout out to my favorite Xbox okay king
king of these other guys yo that's good
that's good though creeper what's going
on I just go Spike's gonna be out yeah
king of his back Lydia Master what's
going on IMAX uh Thomas baladi I see you
Oscar Navarro Necromancer zeld the
Temple of membership like
[Music]
[Music]
a little King's about to come in there
so I'm about to come in here we gotta
take care of some stuff but we got a
good show for y'all good topics some
other little surprises that y'all might
like today as well but you already know
the top is gonna be spicy so I will see
y'all in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and headers be
swearing ain't real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beating they
wanna compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and
snapping and making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start it
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and headless be
swearing ain't real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beating they
wanna compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and Sample
and making it flamable this is that this
is the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still
bi-coastal I got you
that's
[Music]
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold ya I
ain't heard the boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell her Uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we bout to
get started I am well it's not important
who I am uh what's important is that you
are pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all to
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
weed with messaging people on AIM check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you man
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
and we are alive iron Lord podcast Lord
Cognito here talking about the latest
with Advanced GG there's a lot of things
going on with the new product live let's
get right to it
so we got that Focus line y'all this is
that standard that's what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
game in we don't use coffee anymore
we're utilizing this focus on Deck
number two you already know it's my
favorite right here the energy line you
already know birthday cake one of my
absolute favorites completely delicious
this is a pre-workout equivalent and
also doesn't use beta Adeline so you
don't get the Jitters and stuff like
that so it's really good for that and
then the new new we got that hydration
line y'all this is really good for
people who don't like caffeine who want
an electrolyte substitute and it is
really sugar-free absolutely delicious
so you got your three choices once again
you know Cog love is sour you already
know and we're doing this right now so
go get yourself to advancedg.com use
code iron Lord on a checkout this is
something I use all the time got to
support Advanced EG great products if
you want to get your workout on even if
you don't work out you're just gaming
you need that focus and again the
hydration in line for those who don't
want caffeine no sugar electrolytes
you're good to go lower Cognito here
iron Lord podcast peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
if you got work on a Sunday in suitable
because you can listen to this in your
cubicles on the Lord's Day
[Music]
is this talk with the bikes are hot
we'll figure it out we will figure it
out yeah yeah hold on a second might
check it by checking all that when we
fix these little borders a little little
fiction you know saying oh there we go
down we looking right levels is good
make sure the people can hear us what's
going on Fires what's up I see you
what's up y'all can hear what's good
everything good all right
you smell me
hear you hear you and we are live
welcome to the iron Lords podcast LLC
and the lordsofgaming.net as I see you
brother thank you and I apologize for us
it wasn't I didn't mean to not see you
in the bay I had limited time bro but I
come back to the Bay we doing it right
shout out to the man fun oh somebody did
so somebody bought something oh
Anonymous brought a premium all daddy
tank
what is so he knew see me and you
simpatico you ain't even know that I had
it over God yeah like he saw a king with
his take he's like yo I gotta do that
and then also a real quick bro shut out
because someone picked up that um that
Dominus right quick oh I got a shout him
out yeah yeah actually he put it up on
Twitter and I would be remiss shout out
to ready red Yeti 85 at Red Getty 85 he
got the dominance he said that the 3x or
the big boy sizes is up now so now he
could get that dominance up yeah salute
to him and now we can continue back to
what we were doing and welcome to the
iron loss podcast and LLC and the Lords
of gaming.net episode number 268. it's
another Glory Sunday we're back at the
round table on the Lord's day and today
we've got Xbox claim Sony pays two block
game pass
Sony PC ports and PSN accounts Cult of
the Lamb Spider-Man PC and fortnite to
discuss so we gonna get wait a minute PC
I just came back how you bet you bet
like that's the only thing you heard
Spiderman please see
them we could get right into it so let's
get you do stuff for a Horsemen of
gaming those original gaming Knights of
the realm about that brochure
he's about to get Sunset yeah everybody
but make sure y'all get that so those
original gaming nights here at the realm
at the round table my co-host Nicole
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game called lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the attic show how we
doing sir doing pretty good uh once I
want to apologize to the people that
uh that you know we're looking forward
to the added show last week I got stuck
on like almost a 22 hour shift
and do what how how it works at my job
is like I'm in the medical field so if
like legally if no one's there they can
mandate me no no no I'm talking about
you need to step into for the show not
talking about work I'm talking about me
so you just hit me and you just tagged
me and I come off the top row with the
elbow yo we could be like the high flyer
we could be like the British bulldogs I
can't with him I'm Davey Boyce you don't
even know who the biggest bulldog is
that's the footage
they're saying I'm low but I'm literally
right next to the mic you don't sound
low to me he sound really good see the
thing with Adam what happens with Addie
is he don't get up on that mic [ __ ]
yeah like he's supposed to be crooning
or something like you're about to drop
the illest album r b Drake hold on
I don't hear that [ __ ]
I ain't really played a whole lot this
uh this week I did play that code of the
Lamb game yeah yeah uh for
five six hours
we're gonna talk about that here in a
little bit so
okay we're gonna talk about that here in
a couple of minutes so you know I hope
you guys enjoy that you know we have a
good show for you guys man uh you know I
see Spider-Man as the game Spiderman
I guess I guess we're talking about
Spider-Man see what's funny is like
every lore comes to the show with their
own topics and every agenda you mean
agenda
okay
okay every lore comes here with their
own topic and King comes here with an
agenda
you know it's wild you know as well some
of these topics ain't even me
okay okay before we start I want I want
a one if you think King's topic is the
first top pick a two if you keep things
called topic is the second three and
four if you think it's the three third
or fourth topic I wanna see people they
guess right yeah they guess right
now we're gonna see what's going on I
don't know number one second topic too
can you give me that second topic too um
holy Lord here with Spiderman in his
intro
there want a bunch of ones one three one
four two fours couple of two but mostly
ones mostly ones okay so everybody
thinks King's topic is the uh Activision
and I mean excuse me the uh what you
call it the um Sony blocking Game Pass
that's what everybody thinks
no doubt no that shot the Forte he said
Moving Systems right now just for sold
this uh fourth series X console three of
them and with three months of getting
class ultimate all right you always
moving okay that's right my man in the
street with his agenda and his agenda
really matters
he's like nah that PlayStation you don't
really want that right now you're just
getting the appearance yo listen they
joint doesn't even have HDR what my dick
head flicks and Hulu and stuff what
let's see messy and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also
disastradamus
the Lord of clarity and Lord patient of
the iron bank who didn't get me and King
anything but it's cool
it's like I'm being shamed right yeah
yeah
you've got to get the other lawyers that
copies
no that I am fake his King's real tough
around here you talk you put the joint
up in this back then I am back to Heaven
I was otherwise occupied but I was a
king that like addict got the direct
line to the
connected
the attic has a different privilege you
know
it's funny so you're acting like I
didn't literally hit the chat up and be
like yo I'm gonna need that if you want
me to talk about it and it doesn't hit
you up afterwards okay there's a
different level of speed yeah
this is what it is right I immediately
make it clear
the content is needed yeah
you're making content for the channel
[Laughter]
how about you shut up
anyway so what's going on launch teams
all the steam deck blessed this week I
think you ain't gonna say nothing about
this hey anytime we talk about combat
until you got something to say yeah
you bit me into submission
I'm Not Gonna Keep like every time
like you get on to me for doing the
combat top but you want me to do it to
solved
with that Steve that talk out of here
what it is is I don't see equality no
more oh
[Music]
so what's been going on in the world of
a valve and Steve Jackson yeah man you
know
obviously right but uh I mean King your
game of the year that you originally
played on an OG PS4 right
yeah he went away it runs better on the
steam deck wait wait what you talking
about
Spiderman Spiderman that's Spiderman
the game you considered game of the year
that you played on your dusty PS4 okay
Dusty look at how we getting the treated
right runs better on that steam day wait
a minute wait a second on this you said
it's so so it's a portable you do you
have it can you show it sure can you
show it sure
[Music]
I personally feel like you got uh the uh
the whole world is overreacting to that
machine
the whole world
yo what did I tell you about nixes
oh Nixon
mixes sitting in the tree okay
[Laughter]
I was sitting here listening while he
was salivating all over final fantasies
oh it's Spidey I think I might have to
look how awkward though
look how smooth
you got the frame what's the frames
looking like What's the phrase
oh I know why attic bad I know why but
hold on everybody here played this game
match 30 FPS on a PS4 I got it running
at 40 with the city with the city alive
not two people in the streets
20 20. yo no you ain't say they had the
pandemic no who did that for you though
mix it baby your heart baby
I love you Nexus a kid
I'll tell y'all right now
that game next is Nexus is the truth
when it comes to and we'll talk about it
we'll talk about it yeah
I was gonna play Rumble verse so Rumble
verse and you know I don't play type of
games but Rumble verse is the new Battle
Royale game from the iron Galaxy the
guys that have worked on Killers
whatever yeah so the premise of the game
is that it's it's wrestling based so
it's it's melee and it's wrestling they
got see they got you naraka the rocket
got me for the channel five and the coke
fool and this is you I saw it I saw red
I throw a plate I was like he hit me up
I was like yeah I saw that too yo so you
could do you can follow me on somebody
off a building your building it's out of
control you could throw them off the
building and do a flying
elbows
so ridiculous it's Rampage mixed with
wrestling yeah yo they got you yeah they
got you you got your Battle Royale these
games I don't play these games
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the access gamer the
prophet of Xbox so I mean King of the
statue Superman's nothing less than that
premium experience and is the leader of
the fraud alert movement and the general
of the snap snitching
oh it's up it's up now it is up kids
with stop snitching movement is up down
oh Jesus up move again y'all here
telling people not to tell continue yeah
man um first of all I want to thank each
and every last person that showed up
last night combat talk with the King as
we got uh Tia FEMA Lopez coming off of
his uh loss from uh George cambosa
Junior where he lost all the belts and
uh this comeback fight with um compost
was a it was a filling out process it
was the first time for him at 140. he
came in in a light 140 came in at 138.
um I don't think that weight classic
form I I would suggest Tio goes right
back down to 135 a campus was able to
absorb a lot of his shots that normally
dudes get knocked out from walk through
and and I honestly and campus was
walking him down campus is just not an
elite dude and his gas tank ran out
after the sixth round you saw it in the
sixth round it was a marketable drop-off
but
um everybody that came out hung out with
me oh
like I said first 1K came in y'all got
your free drinks they had they they went
a refrigerator magically appeared
nft drinks was there y'all was onions
popping uh shout out to Lemon that
showed up shout out to clowns everybody
um Cricket in the chat see you bro what
up dirt liked your last video your last
video had me almost peeing on myself
right now in this video
into something utterly amazing he is
funny as hell I mean I can't do the
stuff that dirt do dirt get away with
some stuff like
uh pieces of blank for the week and yeah
it's crazy when I was on the show uh
it's like every segment I'm like yo they
do this yeah I'm like I'll be like wow
the streets is real it's funny man shout
out to dirt the crew you know I love
that I love that baby outside for real
he does a good mix
you know on his joint he got some dudes
they don't want to be on camera but dirt
nose power the camera so dirt be doing
his yeah he pulled up yeah he definitely
pulled up okay
um
what I've been playing that you've been
playing this week this week has been a
wild week man this demon call of my wife
is just put me through absolute hell oh
man like every other week is some bread
or something coming out this is it's
absolute torture um so when I do get a
chance to play stuff
it's like me trying to finish up this
Fortnight season pass I'm a slave to
this Fortnight season pass like I gotta
get in I gotta put in some time I gotta
get some yeah they're doing that Dragon
Ball I'm gonna be on there dragon balls
on the 16th yeah I'm gonna be there
right there with you next week so shout
out to Chris
um me and him I got a a chicken dinner
I played with some of the most
competitive uh
rage quitting dudes that you ever see
with a Cavalier I'm just cool with it
like I go in there these dudes be
screaming at me yo where you at I'm
getting shot yo he got down I had to run
go pick up his his dead card
I had 14 uh on my health ball and I had
no Shields I'm weaving through bullets
picking up his dead body going to reboot
him while I have dudes hunting me down
and I did the most James Bond rebooting
of this dude and still I did not get the
credit that I received and I deserve I
received absolutely zero
um I'm a great support team I'm Scottie
Pippen baby yeah that's right don't look
to me to be Allen Iverson no man I'm
Shaq you go be Kobe you go get them
buckets I'm Shaq when he and his Lean
Back years stop that man
I don't like being yelled at man I boots
you baby
with it super super competitive shut off
I'm sitting this one out oh damn baby oh
and the rest of the squad performance
level is not up to stuff yo they they do
this right you can like when you launch
it you have the option this is the most
disrespectful button in fortnite you
have the option of sitting out while
your team goes and plays so I launching
into the world and I'm with uh Queen
Latifah B I'm like Queen Latifah be and
you look at Chris joint and it says
sitting this round out he said man I'm
I'm taking a break my head too hot I
said man if you don't stop with these
games and this you you're gonna catch
your aneurysm but now my fortnite skills
needs to get up um that's the only thing
I've been playing this week uh because I
was trying to play something else but
we'll get into that later yeah
um
I definitely wasn't
with me yeah I know somebody posed the
question yesterday
um because I was talking about something
else and it was like yo so what's up
who'll win between you and Cog in a
fight
first of all we not doing that
podcast I'm testing that man one time to
see what boxing was about
foreign
but anyway so we did that so because of
King and that punch I quickly started
trading MMA because I was like if he hit
me I'm not if it's standing up it's
nothing I'm doing let's stop at this bit
I said but if I grab his leg
and I said I'm gonna learn some music
that yo that literally inspired I never
told you that that inspired because I
was like this I will die in the ring
with any of these dudes with their hair
but his MMA is no joke
I do go ahead yeah I said I do want to
break protocol real quick because uh it
got to address let me play with your
joystick
uh he did do a super chat here she said
that my defining dupe writing about
solved it and make it on the show it's
okay though so I'm just I'm always
decorating just like
like
all jokes here but please don't take
stuff like that to other platforms so
because you know they don't know about
it yeah they don't know about these kind
of inside jokes and I'm sure you know
Maddie probably was reading that was
like yo it's calling Maddie it does like
what is this yeah those are those are
those are jokes and that's that's here
so let's leave our jokes yeah cause we
like we we joke different and we don't
know how everybody does that yeah yo
play my joystick we got DM about you
know
this dude
we know him he's a friend of the family
it's like yo you know about this message
give that message right was it it
symbols I don't know if they do it what
they do guys too yeah they'll be like
something something Cog something
something Matty it's usually something
dirty like yeah but he started it with
that and then but then everything that
followed I that was normal for for for
Last Stand media yes yes the rest of it
was like whoa this is not even a person
that's on that
no doubt you already know it went it
went to the wrong mailbox yes he went to
the wrong mailbox clearly did die yeah
but anyway time on this discussion but
that was pretty much it sir yeah cool no
I'm sorry for you everything I sent you
your gift King so you could play it now
wow until we get to the you know I'm not
playing that way
anyway
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the Shinobi no Incognito spread
that run into the rumble IOP and I tell
you what you want to hear but what you
need to hear shout out to Ben Smith
shout out to Mr Maddie plays holding me
down while I was on work vacation doing
my thing out in the Bay Area you know
what I'm saying but um yeah it was a
good so check it out also decided to do
ultimate him and Mr Jimmy champagne
check that out talk about how you can
start our YouTube channel pretty
informative last word ebontist Thai Guy
Travis had legionless on and the only
person I was able to see when I was out
of debate was Travis so I crashed you'll
kill you guys you gotta watch I crashed
his crib while he was live on air and we
did the joy they did last words okay so
yeah because I didn't get a chance to
see you last month yeah he wasn't
expecting you to arrive at that time but
now he planned to eat eat it though he
didn't know that so he did his reaction
was kind of hilarious shout out to Sir
Taz in the building you already know I
love podcast
you know yo he just run past
just imagine like you creeping up on him
and then the chat just like yo yo yo
Travis is going on what's Happening you
know what I'm saying something so check
that out all yeah also from which song
the cool thing about traveling steam
deck gang first time really taking it
out the house and like six hour flight
going six hour flight going back so I
posted some joints battery life oh no oh
whoa
yeah this is Turbo Express days bro
yeah like if you playing Spidey like I
put I was playing spotty God award yo
solve can we talk about God
[Music]
let me tell you though Horizon
you play Horizon wait a second you just
said you just said
tear this down apart King Praises Phil
for bringing us more exclusives more
games on the platforms
he feels he breaks his gym up for taking
them away
I I praise Jim
for opening up the coffers
spreading the wealth to everyone see you
gotta I look at I look at leadership as
doing something that the that the
predecessor wouldn't have done didn't
think about doing and changing the
direction of the company in a positive I
don't care what nobody say um more
people being able to play Playstation
games in other places that's a damn
positive and for you to be able to take
it on the go someplace that your
PlayStation can't go can't do I can't
think about it yeah that CEO needs to be
shouted out
and and the team behind it the
approaching that illustrious games
on your steam deck listen it's mixes I
will say this it is so this the device
is so impressive it does feel like
having a PlayStation Portable in a way
because there's no way to play
Playstation you know the bangers yeah
like since Veda and the fact like this
is what people talk like switch gang is
always going to be respected don't get
me wrong but it's like
disrespected right now
but it's just like people want there's a
certain group that wants that AAA
experience with the High Fidelity and
the frames and all the the bells and
whips and whistles and National steam
that provides that group I'm not saying
that it's going to beat the switch and
all this other stuff but there's an
audience and I was very impressed with
this joint so I was playing I said I
played all those
um oh I played Detroit I played Detroit
because human over the ass getting Nano
I got a whole lot of Sony situation
as well on there PC edition got my tech
is seven on there rocking and rolling
and shout out to Mr Maddie playing and
David oh so what did you think of
dangaroo
they never played Danganronpa
what's that it's like the visual novel
game with the with the psychotic yeah is
this new teddy bear run around I
terrorizing these kids at this school
it's funny it's funny because it's okay
they have another game that's like that
what's that called where and they have a
whole line of it um it's like evil
something yeah it's three danganronpas
there's three danganronpas but I don't
know all I know is just this teddy bear
run around and basically without
spoiling this joint was squid game
before squid game yeah it's just I got
caught outside look up a video yeah I
give Duke I'll give baddeus bars when I
return to Duke but if he gonna talk
about this damn game
so how far did you get in I did that
because he's like he's like yeah pause
you know who's idiot listen to that yeah
you better be careful who's in here so
um I did because badly was like yo you
gotta do the whole Joy chapter until you
do a trial when I first initially played
on Xbox I didn't get to the trial part
because they be pontificating too much
come on guys like just get to the thing
please so it's like when I finally got
to I'm like oh okay and this is why the
whole argument started because I was
like yo Felix attorney looked kind of
cool and Max like nah what you talking
about that that ain't got nothing on
dang it wrong but I was like whoa easy
all right he's like he's like
now I go front the courtroom joint the
way they do it yeah yeah fire fire
there's a lot of things about it that
are unique and there's still some things
I don't like about it but I'll get it
that deep later but yeah I've been
rocking on that getting that popping off
and all that but this thing is like I'm
out of the loop two weeks in a row dudes
got me gotta Google something yeah
with the fair child we had to do that
you know what I'm saying but yeah that's
where pretty much it so everybody we got
a lot of super chats we got together we
got to get this the patreon hold on a
second yeah let me know I'm up to speed
with the Super Chat so give me a second
roll back and yeah danganronpa's in game
passing off for those at home okay yeah
it's in Game Pass
kick you might like it because it's that
when the bear come out
is it reminds me like it's a evil
personality of a cute fake and it's just
funny but yeah it is quick game for us
to begin yes yes for sure we got a
Donald tackle five dollars for the chat
shout out to my favorite Xbox podcast
King and those other guys
thank you thank you Frank knowledge you
got presents
then we got a necromancer sale remember
for 10 months thank you sir uh hashtag
Sony stops this [ __ ] oh they got to stop
Stitch your movement back here we go for
all those people that have been asking I
told you to stop snitching snatches up
everything at the store hit the
Teespring store right now they're up
right now we had to put stipulations
that we didn't name why who the stop
stitching was for yeah man what is the
bus stop position as a general we don't
we don't we don't cultivate that over
here
as the general of the stop snitching
Movement we we're not about that
snitches get stitches for sure they go
to style snitch Insurance y'all asked
for them last week to stick your shirts
are up links in the chat go get that
shout out to graphic God we got solved
we gotta stop we got Cog to to acquiesce
yes yeah because I thought y'all were
gonna have like a Sony and a logo and
PlayStation and I'm like nah bro we
can't do that
[Music]
you know know you know you know exactly
who out here repping them rats
dude get at me and told me they was
eating well over there certain types of
cheese
[Laughter]
if you know you know
yeah we have next up we gotta
mango I remember for seven months what's
up Laura's last week's episode was one
of the best podcasts I've ever heard
keep it up also I hope that 11 A.M start
time is returning soon wow
today was the day if it was 11 A.M I
wouldn't have been
yo I my body felt like a brick sinking
in the ocean
it's gonna hurt like hell
I don't I don't watch sports when does
that happen you already prepping himself
he's oh God we're the pre-season stuff
football preseason started coming soon
11 A.M
for the life of me I don't know why I've
been the need to that but that's fine
we could discuss it I would be okay if
we moved it to 12 but 11. we could
discuss we could discuss we could
discuss
was talking in the background
I'm so sick and tired of being in Jets
fan I don't know bro if it wasn't for
the Yankees yeah I would have been
committed uh uh videos I mean uh Sports
suicide did the Yankees they've built up
so much Equity yeah that the Knicks and
the Jets eating away at it yep imagine
if you were a Met fan
exactly it's too much with them
and I'm a Rangers Fan because I gotta
have a hockey team right for the Rangers
and yo oh thank God for you dudes yo
these dude it's two teams that's in New
York that just really need to get kicked
squaringly behind in his Jets and and I
had to rep Eli I love Eli
there's a way to put a comment when you
check it out whatever bird y'all buy so
you can put a conversible so we can
shout out the bars where you buy so yo
this first stop snitching shirt was
purchased shout out to another [ __ ]
please leave a comment next time that
was hilarious
yeah no it's it's just I can't take it
no more I'm like but I still I mean they
just put out the uh 30 for 30 with the
Derek Jeter so I just you know watch
that oh hoggy should be he said he was
here
thank you brother it was the 30 are you
all the captain documents yeah the
captain documentary yeah
it's a lot of stuff oh he said he
couldn't actually put in a message
really all right I'll check that out
maybe we'll check that out thank you all
you should have 11. yeah we'll
definitely fix that if that is the case
then after we will fix that and see
what's going on there thank you for
letting us know we got over 600 people
in here let's get those likes up let's
share that out please yes please please
hit that like it helps with the
algorithms to reach more people
just go
yes all right yeah ready let me see it
okay Hector the Macho Man five dollars
oh yeah but I'm not a super chat oh no
the Lords I got my popcorn and I'm ready
for King's topic so all you Sony ponies
keep your crying to the minimum when the
king is talking yeah it was a dude that
came at me and he didn't know who I was
I think it was like yeah yeah Series S
you're broke but I said oh you if you
researched me because he put up a tweet
for like two years ago oh wow I was like
well if you research me like you
researched me then you know I could buy
you the person wow wow I was gonna put
some extra stuff but I'd be like nah
following me so I can't hold on hold on
I gotta get somebody right quick shout
out to the amazing
Paris like our Xbox Cloud team legend in
the game doing this Marvel thing he says
you know what comes the NFL season those
NFL cracks you can get all teams even
the 40 down but you know what we got no
we you know what we got we got slides we
got them IOP slides though links to the
chat go check them out man
stop snitches you know what's funny
at this way we was going to show off
this merchandise and King just jumps out
the window with it yeah we were gonna
show them like merchandise by
merchandise he's like yo what's up
the problem is I'm sorry yeah
was zealous with the stop snitching
movement because it's something that we
as as a community trying to stay at tall
with it we got to stand tall man and you
can't be up there snitching on your
brothers you just can't do it I don't
care what they doing over there
it's the movement man I feel like
but yes we got the slides go rock you
some slides Mr Paris locker I just want
to tell you that that stops snitching
like merchandise I don't know why but it
just looked nice yeah I go for the cups
look fine too thank you um you know me
and graphic God work real hard on on
trying to bring this and this was quick
yeah
yeah no doubt what else we got so let me
see we got Cedric eight remember for 26
months thank you sir Absolution got Mr
Benjamin ten dollars for chat what's up
family love what y'all bring to the
social space 49ers looks real satisfying
and King don't hold no punches truly
proud of my and why people love you guys
and we'll share and support y'all thank
you much love thank you much love bro
with the hundred dollar Super Chat thank
you so much
it's a new follower on it
podcast you guys are hilarious thank you
stick around we gotta have more fun for
you this year walshoff reads the the
chat I'm kind of curious put in the chat
where you guys saw us from like I'm kind
of curious for you know if it was it
another content creator that you saw us
on or like I'm curious where you guys
originally yeah this is like a YouTube
search engine oh hold on I'm curious why
we got seven nobody bought it doesn't
stop stitching it's blacks
that's not snitching in black is fire
yeah
oh somebody got
[Music]
[Laughter]
knocking on
uh we we do plan on doing a merch
giveaway so any March bought today will
be put into that giveaway no doubt yeah
shout out to Dollar Taco he just got the
slots he didn't know where to put my
name in common y'all got to go check
that out y'all cause I'll give you put
me on and said something might be up
with the um the comment part so I'll go
check that out
with it because we we did this so last
minute yeah it could be and it could be
it could be shout out to to to the
support team yeah
I'm gonna tell you right now
I know what it is what is it it it's not
even popping up on YouTube yet so it's
probably it's probably processing
because it just went off yeah that's
probably what it is okay makes sense no
doubt no doubt all right
ten dollars to the chat salute to the
Lords Phil's a nice guy so he plays nice
with PlayStations satya's not playing
games though I got three billion on the
line he's telling somebody who's boss
you snitch on me I'm snitching on you
yeah okay Jesus so first of all Satya is
not snitching yeah
what he said was uh-huh you said
something he said yo
that's the height of hypocrisy uh-huh
these dudes been holding
where did he where did he say that where
did he say that two wrongs
he said he said yo
I don't know what the dudes is on over
here he out here bringing out our names
uh we're gonna get this topic of the
interesting
no I don't know all that that sounds
like real some some real six nine
reasoning
you know I don't like his music
I do like his music
all right gumbo let's go moving on yeah
he was like no he not I said yes he is
yo he was my best pick ever
anyway moving on what we got then we got
black addicts
I think that is so dope
[Music]
four is the legend member for 33 months
thank you so much appreciate that I
usually come on here uh bashing
PlayStation rightfully so but on a
serious note send some love to my wife
she's been in hospital for the last five
days and I would appreciate the kind
words uh much love oh much love to you
your family your wife please let her
recover yeah life partner man yeah for
sure yeah man if we can bring a little
bit of a smile to your face today yeah
appreciate it I hate that for you man
everybody that's here pray absolutely
what's going on we got base 23 bkny 50
Super Chat thank you brother both
companies do the same thing Xbox showed
the PlayStation the formula of exclusive
third-party deals during the 360 gen
Xbox had a parody Clause deal with some
third-party games during Xbox One era
guess you don't talk about that okay
what I will talk about is those dudes is
no longer with the company so again we
don't associate ourselves with rats
that's stuff that practices as soon as
my man got there he was a stand-up dude
Stand Tall dude we don't do that we
don't want no third party deals we don't
want no exclusive we don't want no
parody Let the streets be the streets
Phil stepped up in there real feel yeah
things change because you you have a
parody Clause when you have the inferior
Hardware yes sir that's not the case
anymore so there's no reason for it see
Phil knows that Facebook
people coming for you no they they can
come all they want pulse but I'm gonna
tell you this when real Phil stepped up
in it real failed when he stepped up in
there you know you know remember yo
remember what used to be one dude that
Holyfield fights that would yell out
real deal
[Laughter]
it's different man the dog was on that
other beer my man Phil was like nah we
have to fix our house don't worry about
that we work on our side of the street
see this when you don't have a real dude
in there you don't know how leaders
really work and you talk about you
rapping these rats stop coming in with
the with the rapping the racks and
giving me a reason why stop are you
trying are you trying to say that face
is defended right and what are you
trying to end here justifying these
snitching
don't be pointing over here talking
about y'all doing this y'all did this in
89.
you put the wrong people get out of here
okay then we got let me play with your
choice
here we go I get y'all Fam I'm sorry
about that I'll keep my joystick
exclusively yo
that's right that was kind of funny yeah
keep it over here don't be bringing
don't be putting your joystick yeah that
was definitely a trap Club yeah keep
your joystick over here shout out to
dance go look at our Tass here come the
dude.com hot for the night.com
thank you they seem to be attracted to
our Channel they love it
or what ten dollars Super Chat missed
the last two shows Live Hack cover I
hope you're feeling better brother
absolute Fire interviews and that
platano gato and Viva
had me coughing up a lungs for real
laughter is the best medicine have a
great show guys I appreciate you guys
getting over the vid right now yeah yeah
yeah you're feeling better bro
I'm glad we could provide some
entertainment and some laughter for
everybody clear out those lungs 750
that like 250 likes come on hit that
like y'all come on for the kids for the
children save the puppies
hit the like button
you gotta dude
uh imaginary dude
we hit 400 likes Chicago dropped some
balls oh oh somebody cop to stop snitch
[Music]
somebody said they heard about IOP
through um boom that's what's up
somebody said addict that oh shout out
to the lion she heard about IOP through
the uh in the circle podcast Tech
networks on in my former cast made rest
in peace Cal L he gave us a platform he
gave our platform and time to shine over
there to this day that's still crazy to
me yeah I still can't believe it's gone
yeah no I can't I don't know rest in
peace certain things like him dizzy is
certain things uh it's just man yeah
rest in peace real quick on the Billy's
side somebody's uh the slides
somebody's got the green and white Xbox
okay no no 360 error slides you know
what I'm saying No Doubt keep those feet
right I like that I like that and we got
Donald tackle five dollar Super Chat Ace
Attorney is better than dank and rapper
in every way I will die on this hill
forever hold on I'm with you I'm with
you I I already believe it would you say
it's a attic the sliders yeah I was
about to say shout out to lock in the
building yeah so let's go go Google
clean and look better on your feet than
them crap
[Music]
put those up on on Twitter the whole
Squad can get behind those guys
those chanclas they look better when you
got to Chuck them out of you know
somebody's head for sure
[Laughter]
listen we talk about video games we talk
about video games
in the video game channel had to do that
that's a homeless in your house
continue your video game is crazy Mr BLT
super chat if you need to find a snitch
just blow out your PlayStation 5 and use
that dust to find the fingerprints wow
they with this whole body karate
oh no that'd be good yeah
all right listen I'm talking about video
games man I don't know what you talking
about my man don't beat nobody
he's playing all those Nexus games this
weekend
[Laughter]
continue all right that we got no
chancreta himself crap five dollars
have a great soldiers thank you my
brothers have a good show at it from
Brad wait wait a second
yeah all right no that's right
for the house
then we got cod with the Crocs member
for nine months
now someone's about to change her yes
they know I don't like it now we need
the Crocs with the stop snitching on
them
y'all want to stop snitching slime we
actually we do have more merchandise
coming like I said uh uh we we're in
logistics talking about you know the
merch giveaway but what I will do is
I'll because you guys are selling a lot
of merch uh today all the merch that's
there will be entered into the raffle no
doubt
take more money two dollars for the chat
who's the fantasy champ last year Cog
remind us
exclude
yeah you guys might as well be speaking
a different language
then it's see mad five dollars Sony
isn't blocking exclusivity the
restricted free agent clause and the
contract that allows Sony to match
future competitor deals is the block
okay and Sony
[Music]
play
[Music]
oh so you're gonna have to put in the
chat I'm writing you down since you
can't put your name you got to put in
the chat if that was you
Anonymous all Blizzard or Blizzak
they gonna be at the Microsoft uh event
and they all go walking with you
somebody got the neck gate up the gator
somebody got the gauges you know for the
jokes
oh we got it I gotta talk I got to talk
to squash we need to stop snitching
Gator dude you know what's funny uh the
uh my girlfriend stole my my gator like
like one of the first times I ever met
her I don't remember that work and she
and she had a she put it on and sent me
a picture and she's like I think you
left this here
you don't remember that that was fun
that's a love story right now I got with
her because she stole from me
[Laughter]
at least she was honest about it
you know she ain't trying to hide it she
just wanted to see if you was aware yeah
I respect that I respect that whatever
he got gave it by choice five dollars
per tap I think the adult sites are Sony
getting money for their blocking fees
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you so much man that's crazy thank
you I appreciate that somebody now that
Starfield is delayed Eldon ring is
guaranteed game of the year do you agree
I agree yeah look there there is a
chance that God of War could come out
but I don't like I think I'm unsure
but the thing is is like eldering a
beast man like God of War gotta show up
if they even wanna
that story and that ending has to be so
ridiculous and that gameplay has to be
so ridiculous yeah the pressures are
that DLC gotta be so good
the continuation of something yeah
okay okay
yo shout out to Anonymous again somebody
cop that stop stitching bug in green
Paris I don't know if that was it Paris
said he that was me so I don't know he
did the slides for sure yeah I don't
know if he did this
yeah continue then we have uh Trey bones
Sony out here trying to sell nickel bags
for 100. he's not playing they walk cup
is crazy it's a drought in the streets
raise the
[Laughter]
bricks
Super Chat when is the IOP Crocs
this is for that warm weather by the
beach feet slides
trying to drive that bag off though
because you know we all vote we are
voting no don't listen I've always said
I'll bend the knee
this is how the slides work when you're
going on those International I'm just
not wearing them taking a flight
someplace and you know you're going
through uh the airport terminal I have
your slides on yeah you walk through and
you just slide them off boom boom put
them through a thing put them back on
you on the flight with your slides nice
and good nice and comfy yeah this is
where the slides work in even if you
don't gotta pool around you and you're a
traveling person have them slides on
exactly
yeah with all the slotty I'll just be
that member remember with 50 years to
get married
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
see Crocs is unlimited
[Music]
to pretend that someone say Ace Attorney
oh let's get more people playing Ace
Attorney Trilogy oh yeah there's a code
in there for Ace Attorney Trilogy I'm
assume on the PC I'm assuming maybe
actually I'm convinced that man do they
have Xbox at this point yeah
he just got like how how you just
randomly come up for the Ace Attorney
called in like five seconds after we
talked about Ace attorneys he's got a
PowerPoint or like uh or a an Excel
charts
[Music]
what a hard geek
[Music]
[Laughter]
check out the conspiracy let's hear this
and he he got so much money he's so rich
that he got a a a a a a fake dude to
play him oh my God it's not really Satya
it's really hard geek but the dude that
we see all the time is an actor
Sachi is a fan of big man in the show no
but he's all geek is so about the
peoples he want to be with the people oh
so this like squid game with a dude what
get inside the mix okay I get it yeah so
he made the Persona of hard geek but
he's really sat here but he has the fake
side here that's dead in the front
could be much
like Forza Falls are cold everything is
a switch or something and he got he got
about the community listen I talked to
the man you know play games we met him
is awesome he always gets back if I
disappear good that means I found out
the truth
then we have killer e305 ten dollars for
chat Sony man they lost a chance to wipe
the Empire making making chicks for the
Bravo working Friday night special
chicken wow that's a proud back room
dancer that smell like backwood guts wow
that was ridiculous that was crazy no
punctuation but but you know we don't we
know what's going on
man they had to save some characters yo
King Christopher Hart is asking where is
the Stop Xbox from snitching shirts that
he could buy it's a general feeling of
stop snitching you know
whatever you want
this is the funny thing it just says
stop snitching so you automatically put
it to Sony because you know in your
heart you're guilty are you running with
them rats
I'm just saying it don't say stop
snitching Sony it don't see it's not
certain Microsoft they just say stop
snitching so you felt guilty
rolling with it's snitching okay
welcome five new people to the round
yeah let's go absolutely okay appreciate
that appreciate it appreciate you we got
Donald Taco five dollars for chat how
many times must I tell y'all that Kirby
sweeping the game awards ask let me play
with your joystick that mouthful mode
[Music]
Kirby game came out this year another
one's coming out this year there's two
somebody got the stop snitching work and
green
that was incredible dude if that was
Christopher
are you implying a certain platform with
a certain color okay okay
well you called him out and he did it
yeah that would be interesting about
every weekend he don't do nothing let us
know if that was you for that up there
anyway look you laughing
oh
Christopher is Alby Shaw's son yo
I can't with you don't do that to the
boy Google I'll be showing people that's
too young I swear to God he looked like
a slow bro I see you what up oh he said
it wasn't him okay that or the dude from
Hustle and Flow what's this
eyeballs got eyeballs up so I wonder
what that was about yeah somebody got it
agree so somebody think Xbox that you do
somebody think Xbox mentioned we don't
we don't condone that over here cut that
out
yes sir we gotta pay the bills you know
how we do every single month we say
thank you to our wonderful patrons for
supporting us and and and and really
coming through for us how do they become
a patreon member you can go to iron
Lords podcast at patreon.com and enter
the realm
um at a number of different levels we
have a two dollar level we got a five
dollar level a seven dollar level we
have some crazy things at the 50 level
and above uh we will be they will be at
on uh patreon 2.0 uh there's some things
that need to be changed and amended and
speaking of which uh we did have some
new members of uh that's what we got a
shot about now but um also a couple
people asked for um requests with the
editor 2.0 especially uh got a shout out
about DJ asked me he said if you got
just DM or whatever in reference to some
requests so maybe with 2.0 we can we can
do some of that yeah absolutely um what
we're trying to do again 1.0 was at this
point now how many five years ago yeah
and only I did the death defying stuff
the hot chip challenge only I did the
tattoo on my chest and you know what's
funny
this man's over here saying I did all
this yeah
just acting like you didn't pick some
off the wall stuff hoping that no one
would ever do it and then they did his
off the Wardrobe
oh the Off the Wall stuff was done and
then the regular stuff nobody nobody did
that he's right here we're like no we
don't want to play with each other
I want to play a game with attic nobody
prays oh let's play a game with nobody
but oh king with a tattoo oh King with
the Hot Chip so what what is this
king and the other guy's podcast
is the head that wears the crowd you
it's king of the other guys it's an Xbox
podcast so you gotta you gotta you gotta
run with your title okay
mad because he picked the gun and we
gave him bullets and they shot him
somebody shot me
all right I didn't think it was gonna go
off
there we go we got a couple more before
we jumped in the longest introvers
it wasn't Chris hard it was me it said
it said Kelly Green I thought it was our
camera
he got shot the man didn't think he's
got that stop snitching yo Sean Capri
said which level unlocks the Lord solve
only fans
son come on man really shout out to Sean
Capri
cool man we already gave a cast we
wanted we want to know
I've been keeping up with all the
members and patreons like what I do is I
combine them together we do plan on
doing a little bit more like you guys
like a lot more like Community stuff
with this the problem with that is like
we're so busy but we're coming together
with like goals between the patriarch
and YouTube combined to like yeah yeah
so we're working on that all right what
topic were you on
[Laughter]
my mom would absolutely have an episode
as a kid yeah no no but we got to get
him one of those handys the fake ones so
he could get the one that tattooed on
his face to face yo yo let's get it
let's get a whole attic faced don't do
that to the boys
don't have them out here like Tyson
don't do that you
you does the face tattoo come with the
fame of that tattoo
five dollars of attack playing with me
on that King cheers
and what's crazy is I gotta get some
sleep because I got to do wil me show oh
yeah one day I gotta do it too
boys because he's somebody I love yeah
[Music]
wow what you got I'll uh attic show and
well me oh yes
everybody who keep asking me y'all know
I can't guess this year just yet but
I'll be back I'll be back soon because
they got caught they're pulling cars all
over yeah they pull in the old place bro
them got Edo Vault again
brother thank you yo can I get a shout
out to Baldur's Gate 3 and lorian Studio
videos Do you happen to work for
hilarious videos
like on the rail I don't know if you
actually work for them or not but I love
them games like yeah shout out because
they're the people that make Divinity
I'm pretty sure
yes
I wanted to say it earlier you know
happy birthday uh to one of the most
humblest talented dudes and he's so
under the radar
cut and he's one of the best guys so
good and so humble yeah very fortunate
to have him as part of the team what's
funny is every Super Chat every gift sub
we end up going on a rant for a couple
minutes and by the time we get back to
the super chats it's like five four
years we haven't done patreon yet this
is crazy all right Dad we have shout out
to pragmatic Eagle game five Island was
memberships so that now we have to do a
community stream and I'm I'm actually
I'm sorry but I had missed that the
names of the people that were gifted uh
so put the crust in the chat for Divino
for Commander Rodimus Prime then we got
risk it for the biscuit
salute them you know Carter yes and
Robert Fennell thank you
now we do have to do um oh no he did
another five wow we we have next next
month we have to do a community series
oh yeah no problem we got mad games yeah
I I want to do a pub G with a bunch of
dudes all right no doubt because I
thought I don't know if I want any
smoking pubg don't be afraid I didn't
want no smoking no no fall guys or happy
sandwich slapper
a sandwich but I was in happy sammy
slapping with you right like you guys be
acting like you guys didn't pick games
too uh they did we didn't get a chance
we were ignored we were ignored we
played one or two games none of the
games
for Community night exactly
that was our turn about to look at the
communities
snitching like Randall to miss Finster
oh my God it's moving it's crazy on
nobody from Harlem
why do I feel like Phil is the one
making those responses definitely feels
like he's saying straight to Jim stop
cheesing me bro
that's one thing you don't want to hear
you don't want to hear that shot the
Philadelphia expense
somebody got the slide oh with the black
with the green oh yo these slides is
moving yeah let me find out Phil Dominus
gotta got the green and black slide yo
oh building I had a whole greedy
somebody just got the field down with
this new Phil Dominus with the cup and
white yes oh that's cool
that looks nice yeah we worked on that
man thank you man stop snitches shirt
hoodie in blue somebody get somebody's
aligning it with a platform it's blue
blue hoodie stop snitching
they're gonna
blue they would attach the stats did you
give a color now interesting very
interesting
ain't that right Chris everybody can you
know could direct it at whoever whoever
they feel Chris yes
why haven't you availed of the offline
profile Illuminati patreon
I'm sorry that that was canceled
you know what that one on one time hold
on let me get this next one man this is
my guy right here DJ oros remember for
20 months long ago
he always does that man
yeah DJ I I don't remember if I answered
you no you didn't because he hit me up
and said yeah
I'm like I'll speak to self that's all
been in the bushes my apologies 800
watches please 800 watches on our
intross get those likes up yeah we got
pragmatic Eagle again five
Prismatic bro
thank you so thank you we're gonna do
this Pub G so let's put put the Crush in
the chat for Dr Dingle nut
whoa okay KJ 360. no doubt no we got so
shady oh Shady in the building Shady
then we got bad juju 79
no doubt that you do Astro parrot King
welcome
yeah anybody who's a new member who got
gifted put the crust up man salute that
person salute pragmatic out here getting
more people in the room yeah that's
crazy
that's love use those new emojis you got
you got a lot of little Parts you said
that uh Community is only when we give
stuff oh yes I saw that I was like
somebody gonna watch IOP first of all we
work very hard on on on on on being
respectful yeah or work very hard on
being loyal uh reaching out talking to
people I think that means more than
anything to be honest with you that
y'all guys are here yo trust yeah and
the thing is that I got to defend you on
that King normally I stay you be in this
I respect that but um I have to respect
you with that because it's like yo
clearly the person whoever was confident
don't watch IOP not only do we not just
about giveaways it's about interacting
with our community and I look I'll say
it few interact with their Community
like we do and I'll I'll stand on that
so and if you keep the community in
check like we do yeah like a lot of
communities just let them run wild like
so you know I got got a shout out dizzy
for that yeah yeah because he was real
big on that y'all I want to chat to feel
like people can comments
dizzy is the one that made the
foundation for that because I fought him
over yeah I remember yeah yeah this was
like we gotta establish it he helped us
with our track control
at the time I was just like because I
remember after enough time I was like
dude I mean it it's not like it's it
turned out for the best yeah for the
best because what it is is people with
different opinions can still come in
here and know
I love seeing Christopher Hart every
week no doubt I love it I mean I do
because he knows he can come here and
have a good time you know and don't feel
like he's being disrespected exactly and
that means a lot you know I have noticed
something but you every time someone
gifts memberships it never goes to him
he said anyway right back at him
twenty dollars Super Chat do you guys
think there will be more epic that that
there will be a more epic year than 2022
for Sony Sony admitted that game pass is
a threat calling the Walking Corpse of a
president uh harassing a God of War Dev
exposed for not buying games I don't
know picks and more like this
I'm gonna tell you this wait until the
onslaught happen see right now dude this
is the warm-up when they talk about
throwing in the towel wait until the
onslaught happen you have yo you you
want to see smitten when they are
actively on television and they pointing
dudes out nah she's safe and they crying
because it ain't gonna be no PlayStation
moving on yeah we have selfish burrito
with the 10 euros
not enough content creators talking
about this excellent controlled
exclusive uh BR uh Battle Royale game
with deep purple can't wait for the new
season next I'm team The Rocker blade
point on Game Pass right now even attic
liked it go check it out my man slow mo
yeah slow mo I gotta play in the rock
with you I know I've been away I'm back
this week I'm gonna get back on my grind
and they got a campaign mode The Rocker
blade on Xbox does not get enough credit
for securing a game like this on a
platform and it's fire so dangerous is
giving one gifts
away I think he's trying to get for the
Chris Rice I mean Chris not Chris
righteous Chris
people try to give him a membership now
but so nice okay ready okay then we got
game monomics with the 400 rupee Super
Chat I've been watching the show on
lockdown Lords and Mr Boom the Lords and
Mr Boom show have kept me sane and
motivated during these times I I studied
hard and cleared my exams my results
came in and I am a lawyer
congratulations to you sir good so
hopefully we can hire you
because you know we got news out here
snitches
what employee services for The
Regulators yeah we need the lawyer up
right now
yo shout out again that is fire
fantastic that needs to be celebrated
salute to you man passing your lawyer
exam that's fine congratulations
certified we need Jordan
you guys helped me directly no doubt oh
absolutely brother thank you that's
right thank you
[Music]
it's
only one eye
and this is the prize for something
y'all ain't selling nothing B
[Laughter]
don't come for me unless I sell for you
okay
R Kelly don't let this man bully you
because I'm a bullying the hell out of
him man come back play your bunk girls
patreon
[Music]
all right patreon
uh 10 die I forgot what patreon is
[Music]
Kareem
sir Kareem age salute
oh and that goes too
William Riggs shout out to you boys
maybe he can show me your bill the man
who got them horns just claiming
something said that's him or something
but okay you want something maybe the
one before was him but he won one of
them when it was though they'll salute
to the winners everybody we all good sir
yeah we're good oh see we do give
giveaways I know but people don't know
it's he not man because I don't want
people to think that's what we do we
whatever comes in we push it right back
out we we work very hard and I try to be
as entertaining as possible half the
time I'm happy all they doing is showing
people just expose what they don't
listen that's all that is it kind of
hurt though a little bit because I'm
like that's not what a community is
about the community is any last one of
you that I follow and you follow back as
I go back to follow you can reach out to
me if you're having an issue or
something like that or you need help
with something and if I could I'm I'm
I'm near that's what a community is
yeah yeah you know it just it's one of
those things where I just it bothers me
neither blanket statements about things
that you know they're not paying
attention and the King will help you
here direct me to help you
listen and attic knows that'd be like
who's this King if I don't know
something and attic is
I really love this kid yeah right
Beyonce and he really genuinely knows
real stuff and he and I'll be like yo go
to attic I know about that I don't know
nothing
he helps me out a lot all these stupid
chats are ridiculous what happened now
before we get to that before we get to
the stitches not Rick today and um the
man who got them home said I'm Kareem H
so absolutely okay that's no doubt now
we got your real name
we got Tyler put the crust in the chat
for Tyler B yeah
Tyler B times
we need to rename those eventually
anymore this seems so Blaine
uh Super Chat guess I'll add to the add
to the support Madness and as always hey
King Boo Boo hey Forte
then we got white
I got five dollars in the chat
it's been a fantastic time today am I
right or am I right and what's funny is
nine times that it said he's black
pretending to be white called
irony in it why is it we outside it's
not we are continue
they're doing that on purpose to get on
my nerves we just had someone Super Chat
saying black addicts
the fact that he's white [ __ ] I'm bad
cause he know what he doing you know
everything is investigated perfect
because the New Yorker he doesn't do
that I have to right I know what you do
we are outside yeah we are our brothers
I hope we're having a fantastic time
today am I right or am I right messy
messy do it again
we have what we see DJ auros five
dollars a check well the Forte is adding
to the madness I am too and hey bestie
also stop hates me I do not hate you
everything I'm gonna get on with the
show
I'm supposed to be appear on podcast
next week and I still have yet to
confirm with people so oh yeah I
apologize to all of them no doubt No
Doubt
um
then we got beyond the river sticks put
the question beyond the river sticks and
Sir Tim Pearl welcome to September 21
yeah welcome to that request of the chat
all right
good 21 members all right cool cool
so much love today
um there's a pole
and then people wonder why a podcast
that's so long we literally spent 30
minutes reading super jump but we guys
are literally keeping us hospital do not
put that out into the world don't do
that
Elizabeth we got the best community
going that this this is like we could
play but we don't really complain we
love the love this joke it's jokes it's
jokes but look look if our biggest issue
in this podcast is we have to read the
support then that that's a pretty good
issue exactly that's a good problem to
have so salute to the people four 14
likes man let's get those likes
790 people in here hit those let's go
anyway last week's all people resort to
any people have spoken with the recent
response by Sony The Regulators stating
Xbox owning Call of Duty has no rivalry
it's console Choice then Microsoft
telling Regulators the Activision
Blizzard doesn't produce must-have games
who stands to you more closely align
with the winner of the three-way ILP
poll with a dominating
78 of the vote
was the messy Lords I don't care we all
know Sony and Microsoft both tried to
finesse the fed's group coming in at
second place at 20 21 of the vote was
Microsoft stance is the most accurate
and in last place for the first time
ever with no
percentage of vote zero percent zero
I've never seen this what Sony stance is
the most accurate
so no one believed in Sony stands but
overwhelmingly it's 78 believe that they
are both um trying to finish the fast
songs kind of lines with where you at
well since you're the winner what do you
feel about the the people man yeah yeah
hey buddy snitching right about now
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
but what about with
heat oh hold on they still buying them
somebody bought this stuff
I got the cup added to take it stops
drink your coffee you don't snitch on
nobody
Super Chat have solo two dollars with
that they are legit helpful they helped
me get started yes sir this is one of
the individuals that I have to get back
to yeah I'm solo my apologies yeah yeah
salute has solo baby soon as I get my
thing together then I'll be over there
too
um shout out to slow we got more slow-mo
back slap six dollar Super Chat giving
one more dollars and four times just
cause by the way damn why are you in
competition with with your own shout out
to the DPS podcast one of the great best
podcasts out there two-man group the
division is back like we never left a
destiny Guardian is a skid marks of a
division agent do you hear this landed
yeah wow that's cool I finally got some
content drawings of a division agent
that reminds me of a very old movie
we're not doing stories
I see that slow-mo from a reformed
school girls I see that yeah
Eagles fan 76 five dollars stupid chat I
just jumped into the show that I missed
all the topics on the Sony blocked the
topics
read the next one song I think this is
hilarious we got Soma King pop out Super
Chat worst thing about this podcast is
all the damn super attacks
that's the funny things
foreign
Warren and The Verge Microsoft claims
Sony pays for blocking rice to keep
games off Xbox One almost said I know he
would respond
oh my God and then somebody just dropped
another city get it yeah
yeah I don't have anything to say but
anyway so shout out to The Verge and he
says look it's part of a document sent
to Brazilians administrative Council for
economic defense you know what I'm
saying the Xbox firm
um claimed that Sony actively attempts
to inhibit growth of game pass by trying
to prevent content appearing on it and
they said considering the ex that
exclusive extract that exclusivity
strategies have been at the core of Sony
strategy to strengthen its presence in
the games industry and that Sony is a
leader in the distribution of digital
games Sony's concerned with possible
exclusivity of Activision content is
incoherent to say the least Microsoft
claims and the documents published by
Cade it only reveals once again a fear
about an innovative business model that
offers high quality content at
low-costed Gamers threatening a
leadership that has been forged from a
device-centric and exclusivity focused
strategy over the years and then it
claims Microsoft's entity Microsoft's
ability to continue expanding Game Pass
has been obstructed by somebody's desire
to inhibit such growth Sony pays for
blocking rights to prevent developers
from adding content to Game Pass and
other competing services and then they
talk about
um you're representing how some of that
stuff kind of came out and the blocking
of third-party deals in the epic epic
versus epic Apple lawsuit and then they
said continue in the document Microsoft
claimed that Sony does not want
attractive subscription services to
threaten its dominance in the digital
distribution market for console Gamers
arguing in other words Sony rails
against the introduction of new
monetization models capable of
challenging its business model so this
is the talk of the week the direct
response from Microsoft King this is by
far the talk of the week yeah this is
the talk this is everywhere that's the
hottest thing on on social media right
now King this is your topic well
actually it's my topic excuse me so I
apologize everybody thought it was King
this is my I will take this one because
I thought this was very interesting so
I'll bring this to the round to the
round table Robert's like you know now
that this news is dropping Microsoft
firing back after you know Sony like
what do you think about that's not what
you had it
I mean did people expect Sony just to
like not do anything like look just
because they've done nothing but show
that they don't fear game pass but they
do recognize it as a Pawn on the board
they don't fear it I don't think they
fear game pass because I do think that
they know that their their content has
quality in the statement though they did
say that game but they're terrified yeah
they did they did say that day pass was
like that only Microsoft was capable
come up with nothing yeah they said
there was nothing that they did kind of
put they did kind of say that we can't
stop him but they can't stop him but
they're narrow
yeah they say that but if you put all
their games in in their subscription
service tomorrow it would be different
they can do it they just don't want no
they can't do it because they need that
money to pay for blocking okay let's
addict finishes and then you can talk
about what you want to talk about
like regardless what they say they can
they can compete with game pass but at
the moment they don't really have to do
what is necessary to compete with Game
Pass their games are still selling very
well so they don't need that that
Revenue now I think that they they see
game pass as a threat to losing consoles
and stuff like that but I don't think
they see like Game Pass is a big threat
to their overall business and but you
see them doing stuff that is like look
like they recognize it man that's the
queen on the chessboard they're like we
gotta make sure that we take that thing
so that they are strategically putting
pieces to Ambush at their you know
reducing the price of PlayStation now
when it was still that to 999 ironically
what uh Game Pass was there you know uh
merging because they don't have really a
whole lot going on they're getting more
Indie Games into the game into their
service day in day you see them putting
strategic pieces on the board that way
it that Queen goes for the king they can
do something
and and your thoughts about them with
the comment about Microsoft's comment
about them paying for it like just
specifically how you feel about that
part it's like I said like what what
does people do people expect that you
know
people pay a lot of money for these
marketing deals like a lot of money and
to me are you feel comfortable going up
and saying look I'm going to give you x
and x amount of dollars the market or
get uh to Market your game and then not
leave out the fact that okay why is if
we get the showed what's the point I
have of the marketing when the
competition has your game for a
subscription on the other side of the
lake so it's just like in order for them
to properly Market they have to do that
okay there's no way to thoroughly Market
a game when at any time the competition
can come across and be like yo we know
they got the marketing but do you want
this money
and it's just like look they had to make
strategic Clauses in these contracts
because there's no point in marketing a
game if you can go into a subscription
service such as game but keep in mind
like I do think Game Pass is the bulk
thing that they're putting in this in
but they see subscription Services
popping out everywhere you know we're
seeing it in the TV stuff right now uh
there's a popular anime that has been
dormant for years called bleach Disney
just won the the bargaining the
publishing rights for this this anime
and it's coming on Disney plus so it's
just like they see these popping up
everywhere and sure stuff like Ubisoft
EA don't really do other people's stuff
but they don't know where that's gonna
go they don't know what's the future oh
and holds if they don't know what
happens with stadia sure stadia is
pretty much dead but you don't know if
they try to re-imagine that to something
else like they're covering all of their
standpoints like look we don't really
mess with the subscription services to
that degree but we do they don't mess
with the subscription services to that
degree but they just put out a nuisance
I have myself muted for a minute
it was a lot of stuff that I did not
want to jump in but they just launched a
whole new service about their services
that they don't really mess with it to
that degree but I but I said that's one
of the that is one of the pawns that
they have around the board to where I
don't think they I don't think that they
made that to compete with Game Pass I
think they made that if they had to hit
the red oh [ __ ] we lose at all
we lose we're losing cells we losing we
losing Japan we losing Europe we lose it
so that is it a red button so it is a
response to gay passes no I've always
said that I've always said that them
doing they're making strategic things to
where they don't know if they'll have to
go that direction but they want to have
the the building blocks that they can go
that direction that they have to right
the adaptability the pivot that me and
you talked about before the past that's
why I said I feel they are different
from like PS3 Sony which probably
wouldn't even uh adapt when you're going
I don't care it's so crazy different
from PS3 Sony these dudes out here
snitching and blocking and doing all
types of things the old Sony would have
just manned up and fought these dudes is
rolling on their belly and snitching
pointing people out I'ma mute myself
when it comes to we already knew about
the closet the Resident Evil remember it
was it was Robert Village was going to
come to Game Pass and their contract
literally got leaked like the contract
for Resident Evil got leaked and it set
in there it can't go to subscription
services for like a year so we already
knew this was happening I understand how
this is news to me like I don't
understand well it is in the sense that
we let's be honest we're usually never
never privy to this information about
yeah this is stuff we shouldn't yeah
this is stuff we really I love this new
world
the information where the cameras on
every block so it's like yeah we like
this is something we don't really get to
see that's what you know we get to see
how dudes really something something
like this it is competition it's like
this is not competition
Sony has to make these preparations
because like I said like putting a brick
in your glove but what's the point
especially after they buy Activision the
remaining Publishers they make I they
make deals with they're gonna have to
even be extra like you know what's crazy
the fact that Microsoft made a service
that's costing that that that's costing
Sony more money because now they have to
pay Publishers more money to keep theirs
please buy games
it should be done
you going all extra long this has been
45 minutes
I've never seen King so adamant
what's crazy is so these dudes is
margarito plus is a Paris man you're
really putting bricks in their gloves
man
oh man import you we caught you with the
bricks in your gloves is is it out of
your system now finish addicts or
something oh bananas yes okay now I I
formerly bend the knee to like King talk
no it's actually self-sters
I mean by the time by the time it goes
around King's gonna talk
as soon as I say something left and he
don't like he gonna jump in yeah
so you know how you gonna jump in the
oil so but anyway
what do you feel about these uh
explosive claims oh for Dusty you know
why I get this all spare and Love and
War and the console Wars alive and well
clearly they're just fighting them in
the trenches no no we get along fine you
know in front in front of companies but
you know behind the closed doors it's a
whole nother thing and I just find
they're both being so petty yeah yo the
pettiness of both sides
nah but he did this
we keep hearing from people saying this
is
all right
on the series that's what people always
say we want them to bet to clash more
often and now they are and they are
they're just they're not doing it in a
public forum but you know like like King
said it's a wonderful world we live in
we want that crash at Nintendo building
exactly so I you know to me it's just
funny that this is happening
it is Sony listen they know full well
that it is in their best interest that
game pass topples on itself Activision
Blizzard deal does not go in like they
know absolutely 100 isn't their best
interest for that not to happen right
so when you talk about what Microsoft
says that they're blocking or whatever
this is
this is like
who made the decision they don't gotta
do this
you feel they have to do this what is
going to do this is new Sony let's do
something this is new soda I'm just I'm
I'm trying to not interrupt okay okay
put to attic's point when when Microsoft
takes your game
and puts it and makes it a better value
on their platform and it run better
that's a problem
that is a problem
they should have offered it in that on
their service long time when it comes to
the show thing the first thing they
should have done the moment show was
announced on Game Pass to say okay
but to me just because it's not their
bottle you have to Pivot when someone's
making when someone's making your game
that your developers get it on your
platform look like a better value than
something that's on your planet
sometimes like that particular and let's
be wrong wouldn't happen like any game
it's like that's the only thing like
that it's like maybe they should have
bent the knee and put that in their
PlayStation Plus now maybe they should
and even though like when you look at
the numbers actual sales sales were
highest on a PlayStation platform
because people just associated with
PlayStation
but bro like it makes me wonder was
there something in there that said
through sales but what about engagement
oh engagement definitely game pass
because for a lot of people on this side
it means nothing
a lot of sales mean nothing now what
sales means actually nothing unless
you're talking about engagement if
you're starting to look at that point
but sales is important sales is
important for that model for the old
generation
so you shouldn't be talking about this
you should be like right engagement
matters shout out to Phil Dominus
Maximus Spencer for teaching us that
engagement is more important than actual
numbers because dude just keep in Pace
with lesser systems out there
[Laughter]
let me mute myself again
like I said like snitching going on on
both sides here you know and and to me
it is just posture okay it's not but
okay it is snitching on both sides King
oh cool
are you supplying that Xbox went to
court there's paper what I'm saying is
if I get into a fight with a co-worker
at home
that stays between us because we both
know we getting fired right we we both
know we getting fired if this comes out
right this is my thing is maybe where it
is be the bigger person oh so so you say
Xbox they have to go back because both
of them
down to their level
this might as well be that Meme where
they're in court they're like point out
the
person's just pointing right at him
let's say this right and you brought up
the scenario you and a co-worker get
into a fight you black the hell out his
eye
he walking down and the boys come out
and say yo what happened to your eyes so
you don't know what happened I ran it I
ran into no no then he go this is what
he did because the Brazilian said oh you
opposed to this he said they black my
eye
um Sovereign
exchanging blows but I really what had
happened was he didn't say his side when
that happened right
hold on the boss comes to you and say yo
why you punch Melvin in the face and
black his eye on on company time what's
up with you and you just said yo Melvin
stuck his finger in my cheek no no you
not only did you say Belvedere you say
yo but Melvin been doing he keeps keep
it keep it sabotaging my food back at
80.
it says he said uh-huh he said this he
said yo Melvin suck his thing in my
cheese and he'd be doing it all month
all right
the ball's gonna turn around and tell me
bat thank you for being honest both of
y'all seeing the door
the real your real boss is gonna tell
you he's gonna look you in the face and
say that's right Melvin need to catch
them hands you know what's crazy you
guys are saying Melvin the mindset you
know what's crazy you guys are saying
Melvin and my dad's whole family
shout out to Velvet but like but here's
the thing he could have still talking
and and when the boss had to say yo mama
we both keep our job exactly he could
have handled Melvin after the afternoon
the real bosses say oh okay evaluate the
situation Melvin hand called for them
hands hey Melvin called for stop
sticking your finger in his cheese
though he had to give up Melvin evil
I'm gonna tell you this Melvin's gonna
be more reluctant than knowing that
Refrigeration all I'm saying is that I
the way you really handle it is you have
a fair one yeah
snitch he need the bigger person
in reality
so shout out to Melvin
you you out here acting like Microsoft
wanted to go to office they were cool
they had a choice
everybody else said no we don't care
what's happening it means
wait a second these dudes can't this
can't go down because of this this that
and the third we can't do this and they
start crying on stuff that they can't do
because of them but they didn't say
but we have taken measures to block
these dudes they did not say we are
doing this all that they did was a
snitch right because it doesn't move you
you snitch and leave out pertinent
information
you snitching and you lying I'm of the
mind that omitted information is not
lying
every song could have easily but they
tongue into just walking and cuss them
out under their breath but it's all
right the moment management says
something like but you know what Sony
wouldn't leave me alone for a month
they could have literally when that
paperwork came through they could have
been like now we good because a real
dude gonna be like I'm gonna handle it
in the streets this dude gonna see this
God of War gonna beat them so bad but
they scared in their own DLC so them
news is like but two wrongs don't make a
record because again with management
goals oh I'm so sorry I mean no it's a
good discussion though we gotta have it
no no cause I got it I got bought okay
okay okay continue that part by the time
it gets to him yeah you're right you're
right continue all of that to say this
and and the the fear is real yeah the
fear is real because again if this had
been if this this purchase is going down
one publisher to another publisher not a
first party not specifically Xbox that
is their direct competitor they don't
really see Nintendo's direct competitors
if it were anybody else this this would
not be their statement they'd be like
just like everybody else that they got
asked it would be like whatever you know
whatever we don't care
it shows you again the competition this
gen is real that moves that Microsoft
has made has forced their hand forced
their hand in a way
that if they can help it they're going
to stop the stuff dead in its tracks
anything they could do so again they
were honest about it but you know people
say oh it's Brazil regulation board
whatever this is the statement across
Sony period This Is Not Just Brazil
saying this this is a statement across
on so the thing about it is it's going
to be real interesting to when when
these free to play games come out on the
on the Sony platform and we really see
start to see what their their plan of
attack against against Game Pass really
is yeah it's gonna be real interesting
to see how that pans out because it is
the obvious the obvious or the plan of
attack is is one the plan of attack in a
lot of ways their plan of attack is to
tell
your plan of attack is in a lot of ways
[Laughter]
they're taking Microsoft out the window
Microsoft's looking at the passengers
and said that's his gotta be well he got
drugs in his cribs
in another state
I tell you that's a fake idea what's in
his mouth that's the dude that's doing
too much stuff that's way too much
talent continue
to point out that he had a gun
we stitched you that we couch your
snitches
[Laughter]
the registration Nintendo said nothing
everybody else said nothing Sony said
that's his
anyway so are you good I mean what else
you had to say Sir so kid clearly has a
lot to say about this okay what do you
feel about you know first Microsoft's
claim that that Sony we know we know we
know we we know
we don't okay so what we first know is
yeah
in my ignorance I said Sony should have
put uh MLB the Show in uh their service
it can't
once it's on like uh Microsoft service
for whatever yeah right good point as
old which means Microsoft has those
Clauses
you learn
Behavior oh but if if if you grow up
getting spankings the odds on you
spanking your children is very high
because that's learned behavior right
you have to break that behavior we broke
that behavior when we was getting
spanked in the 360 era I mean well the
Xbox the OG Xbox area into the 360 era
we had to break that behavior where Phil
stepped up to the Xbox one all right so
we stepped away from that stuff but we
had to be pulled back in anyway
they couldn't do that old Sony would
have just said cool you got it in your
service what we're doing is the uh the
bonus bundle where they putting in MLB
to show in every PlayStation 5. that's a
lot though yeah but but this is how you
counteract that you know you have a way
to freeze give it away
because you you know why you know why
the engagement level is higher over
there anyway you don't care about it
yeah they don't they don't care and they
they can't do it because we found out
why they're not giving y'all anything we
found out why the service ain't giving
you anything we found out
we find out why your games are seventy
dollars plus tax we find out why you are
more we find out why the scalpers are
selling you for more we found we did
everything
said that
they have nothing
oh you talk about the comments oh okay
okay nothing to compete okay
we were saying I'm reading between the
lines
what I'm saying at it is all right at it
what I'm saying is Sony said nothing
they make nothing that means nothing at
that point out nothing they can conceive
of nothing that they doing to mess with
Call of Duty but they also said their
own services that they just launched
with Game Pass so he is right their
thoughts is that's their gun we gotta
get them out the game by any means
necessary uh I don't care the cops just
pulled up they just started the
Inquisition on what's Happening here
what's going on which everybody has to
report to and everybody was in the car
nobody said anything
nobody said anything Nintendo's in the
back I mean me I know nothing
yeah
[Laughter]
what's up don't ask me questions every
everybody
talk on the phone with their lawyers
EA said hold on give me one second
I'm sorry
you know you ask everybody the only
person before anything uh license and
registration that's his gun
gun nobody know anything but yet oh boy
is snitching
okay
DC just looking looking at Microsoft do
you have a gun sir you have a gun in
here you think yeah I got a gun Call of
Duty Call of Duty is the guy Call of
Duty yeah Sony just sitting there so
he's like yeah it's in his glove
Department Tony gave him the serial
number what type of books wow every yo
they told them everything and then they
said and please get out of here nothing
I got right now I can compete with this
dude I had to get in the car with him
listen man I've never seen this I've
never seen this especially from a tough
dude like from the tough dude from the
bully oh you're the bully and this is
always true my mama always told me you
punched that bully in the face and you
stand up to that bully and you're gonna
see how much of a cow would he truly he
this is the first real fight old boy has
really had
this is the first two fight y'all
one time Microsoft need to show that
money they got all this money they need
to compete so what happened now they
fighting now
that's their bullets and I told you
right now they went and they got the
really squabbling in the streets the
realest dude the dude that you want no
problems that was the other bully that
you was nice with right you you started
buying him lunch you started buying him
lunch but then you came into school that
day and you found out that he brought
Mike Tyson a whole outfit and Mike Tyson
living in his house now
so that lunch your lunch don't work no
more and you like yo I gotta stop them
because they move in on the 31st I got
to stop him from moving in and you
wouldn't say that's a trap house Mike is
going to
Mike is going to be in the trap house
and
because you don't want them hands with
Mike yo I've never seen this level of
afraid of afraid when you diss everybody
on your roster you just everybody yeah
they said there's nothing we could do
nothing to know what no one can make to
compete with me so you know Michael's so
upset right you listen
they had these practices in place
they've been doing all this stuff
they've been blocking this then the
paperwork come out that they've been old
it has to be parody it has you know if
if you're going to put the game on their
platform
it can't be you can't use the
capabilities to the maximum I don't know
about that property well it has to be
parody right okay I guess
all right so if it has to be parody that
means it can't be greater than all right
so it has to be equal of course I don't
remember these documents
so because there's been there's been a
lot of speculation about that right like
right the card
that that Cod is going to be blocked
from being on Game Pass because that
would be too much of an unfair Advantage
for that that's part of the argument
right it's like okay if they control it
it'll be on Game Pass it's not gonna
matter that it's still on our platform
that's the argument right and
there's some people who believe that
Microsoft is going to be forced to not
put that game on Game Pass instead of 70
on play well well the the thought
process is initially in Texas remember
Sony still holds the marketing rights
yeah so once so let's say the marketing
rights I think allegedly 2024. so let's
just say hypothetically the deal and
completes Microsoft gets Activision
Blizzard this 2023 they can't put it in
game pass because the exclusivity is
still I mean the the marketing rights
that Sony has with Call of Duty might
prevent that you know I'm saying now
obviously there's still you know they
could theoretically do that you change
things
all the old ones in there right they can
put all the old ones right they can put
all the contract yeah if that contract
hasn't been amended right right if it's
assuming that it hasn't been amended it
stays as it is and Microsoft retains the
language like they did with death Loop
right and Ghost Rider talking they
didn't change it they say yo y'all had
to we will honor it pry to US own it
right that's that's what 2020.
the death Loop and goes where are two
different things with those who
specifically and those were those were
going to be Sony exclusives right yeah
correct it's kind of not as different
it's kind of interesting that we're
about to hit that year mark and we
haven't heard nothing and we have not
heard it
well you can't talk about it yeah you
can't talk about about it yeah until
until it's done though they literally
can't talk about a lot of things but who
the dude
come out September
yeah I can't remember until we got to
see September but then again we're
assuming that it's one year we don't
know the length of the country we don't
know they've been locking up two-year
contracts yeah it could be two years
of my argument for me okay they've been
in the background doing this snake stuff
paying stuff to keep stuff off right
they've been doing all of this so
Microsoft is just pointing out listen
they have been doing all of this stuff
they've been pointing out right there
was they said they said hey Microsoft
what's this in this contract
what
um this redacted part right here we got
it why is it gonna be rejected
they said okay so they unredacted and
they saw they was like what's this part
right here oh that's where they just
blocked games from us
but all that stuff on the page
he said this is what they do with us
dude I'm gonna take the fifth but all
that stuff on that paper that's real
[Applause]
yeah yeah
all the stuff that's unredacted
they did that why could you see Sony
like put like you know you got the FCC
that's sitting there reading it like he
goes on the shoulders like you think
that's right you think that's right
like that's unfair you think that's
right continue get me to save my
teammates
it's just hate hey
is it true what they're doing is what's
happening well whatever the paper says
hey whatever you see
you secretly you can read right I know
we always say he said you graduated from
Harvard yes
by that age you knew how to read right
do you know how to comprehend yeah well
everything on that paper is what it is
don't bring me back in this courtroom
hey if Tony is still searching it did he
leave a kid this is still doing more
stuff
just sitting there just pointing out
he's like man like you know just just be
honest with me Sony
lying too
comes over with the highlighter
so I was like did you read that
yeah so the king said it's not very
important it's like they lying too
oh I mean not lying as well as snitching
bro I'm not going to allow you to
do that
Microsoft is giving back my Sony is
taking the money that they get that ill
gotten days yo all that DLC that you're
purchasing all that uh extra Rumble
stuff in the air sound stuff oh all that
ten dollars you're like why is somebody
charging all this extra ten dollars they
Gathering all the ten dollars from
everything
and they're blocking they're using it to
block could you imagine if they actually
had confidence and said you know what
let's put this into some offense let's
take all this extra money we gouge in
the public
anything let's take all this money
instead of spending Millions upon
Millions on blocking
let's just reinvest in ourselves and
stop giving them the same bacon egg and
cheese that they've been getting
y'all been talking about Forza gears
yeah uh and um Halo for forever
God of War yeah all hashtag just once
yeah you're right and Horizon you're
right right did you say naughty dog here
and there right I'm gonna tell you this
let's say Microsoft does still they
can't put uh Call of Duty inside Game
Pass and the deal goes through before uh
Thanksgiving like I said right all right
we don't Microsoft can say well their
marketing rights is up in 2024 right
there's no Call of Duty in 2024
um we're going we're not annualizing it
so the the market didn't run out then in
2025 Call of Duty comes back is in Game
Pass day one you have that uh that month
head time and then you guys got to pay
the 75 if you want to play stinking
dirty you want to play in the mud
we're just getting we're freezing and
put it on the Shelf until the contract
went out it does it it depends if the
contract requires a game release because
maybe the contract says you could be
right but I'm saying maybe the contract
says you have to release two more Call
of Duty games and then we have you know
with that I don't know Call of Duty
World at War whatever give them give
them give them something that's not I
mean that could be that could be a
remake of modern warfare three it could
be a remake of Black Ops one like
because there's Call of Duty this year
there's no Call of Duty next year all
right next year some gonna be some
premium drop for for whatever Modern
Warfare two and war zone for next year
war zone 2.0 I don't know I don't think
it comes out now I think it's next year
that it comes out 2.0 but yeah I could
be wrong about that but there's no core
Call of Duty next year
I think that argument I'm more alignment
with the you know the way Saudi has
aligned themselves for the past
generation with the hashtag just as much
as I love them right the diversity the
lack of diversity in the first party
lineup from AAA standpoint now can cause
concern when you see this major
franchise that you play marketing rights
to try to shore up your deficiency now
could be taken you know taken away from
them
if you've done I was gonna get my boss
no no go ahead no I mean look I'm sorry
yo guys it's like it was soft like
addict like what they supposed to do
like like at this point it's like look
I don't really have a problem with the
exclusivity stuff we can't screen
competition but then when it happens
yeah that's not right I don't got a
problem with the ACT listen I've got a
problem with Microsoft with acquiring
companies you know I'm Lord acquisition
I don't have a problem with Sony with
their schools and stuff I've always been
consistent and now the only time I was
in my feelings and adequate is the the
secret extension I just wish I knew when
the deal was going to end because I
remember when the destiny thing got me
in my field okay what's the question no
I just it's just one question because
I'm noticing a level of hypocrisy not
with you not with you okay all right the
level of hypocrisy is
is doing this uh gatekeeping and
blocking off games and pay for
exclusivity
but that was then I'm talking about what
they did no because what what did Phil
come out and say yeah we we have to talk
about exactly when the change happened
and change happened with Phil and he
said those marketing deals don't do us
any good right but it doesn't omit the
fact that it happened it still happened
rise of the Tomb Raiders still have to
be better no I get that I get listen I'm
with you on Microsoft you stupid new
strategy I get it yo play everywhere but
they die you trying to get somebody to
play a game that they not trying to play
like that they're just like yo this is
how we do it over here Hardware Sales
right you over there saying nah I'ma put
my software my service everywhere and
everybody could get down right so your
model threatens my bottle it listen it's
like my thing is what they supposed you
did listen
I'm gonna be keeping a butt like if I'm
so I'm not letting you run around with
no MLB to show and outriders in your
service making my 70 joint look like
trash and and nobody devaluing what I'm
doing like every time they put one of
them third party choice in there
it theoretically does devalue this
we saw what happened with MLB the show
we saw what happened with outriders so
if I look at it it's like oh no no it's
like we dating you gonna sign this paper
and you gonna be like after one year two
years you ain't going nowhere until no
other services until I tell you so you
think that's okay I don't have a problem
with it that to me that's like what
you're supposed to do I'm not gonna let
them run around and get the girl like
bungee that say I don't care what you
say on that paper and I'm not saying
well she got he got to do what he got to
do because well I ain't got no FPS games
and I need to do something after I saw
that Call of Duty running around over
there with you
okay so all right so this is what I want
to tell you let's go because we have
over 900 people let's get let's get
those likes up and share it out because
I know some developers here but I'm
gonna talk straight to you let's go just
do the bungee tell them now
true but you gotta I see your extra bag
I see you trying to lace the cake with a
little bit of extra Icing at the top and
now we're just gonna take the best dice
to see here take the base cake and we're
gonna make sure that our game is not
gonna be gatekeeping if enough dudes
take a stand oh my God and if you if you
if you're strong enough you staying with
the team and enough dudes take a stand
don't take the back don't sell your soul
stand up there stand up and be like nah
you gonna play like everybody else
you're gonna wear the gloves and you're
gonna put a mouthpiece in and you're
gonna fight like everybody else
to take all those ill-gotten games
because they they overcharging you dudes
we we gonna make them pay for what they
did to the coke the counter
the counter Kegel people will say well
if you care about it so much if I'm this
third-party Dev and so he's giving me
this bag to keep my joint out of Game
Pass then I could come to you and be
like um excuse me Mr um Microsoft
someone is giving me this to keep it off
where's your bag what you mean we don't
do those exactly so you're for the
community for the community we out here
for the community but what we could do
is you could get your stuff inside Game
Pass and we can get all over here and
you can put your game out over there we
don't what you give it about over there
what you give it a bag for you're giving
me a bag to put it on gay path so what
that's somebody's like foreign
don't go over there and pump on Sony
block Sony locking the block down they
blocking
there's also plays out all I'm saying is
not good for the community listen I know
where you're going but everyone
situation is different right right some
people ain't strong like Bunchies in a
different position they can be like yo
bro I don't think there's another
developer yeah we take a third-party
joint or you take any little first party
joint right you look at a seafood you
look at you getting Marketplace front
page on a PlayStation store like your
little joint gonna get crazy now you
look at the level like looking on the
flip side look at Xbox look at as dust
Falls be a song without that right do we
think that game would have got any of
the exposure it got if it wasn't for
that game pass you know what I'm saying
that back so to me it's free market I
like to be the devs is winning this I've
always said this I look at squid I look
at the devs it's like yo let them battle
it out I could take a bag from whoever I
can raise the price up like a word Game
Pass giving me this Sony what's up you
know what I'm saying yo where okay you
gonna pay me for exclusive marketing yo
I'm going over it to me is good or they
can do yeah you know we're going to sit
here and rock with Xbox until the
contract's up yeah and then we're I
think we're gonna come to you or get
more money bro you can even do it like
this addict check this out if you spawn
you could play both of them you could be
like all right I ain't gonna take the
Game Pass back right now because some of
them are doing it right officially I'll
take the Sony marketing rights
Rock for a year to get that back then
once it's over Yo Game Pass what up baby
yo you want to jump in all right
Microsoft you can get two bags if you
smoke we have to eliminate the
competition
that's why hashtag no PlayStation sex
has to happen Okay once all that is over
with and once they are done and in the
bushes I want to know how far that money
wouldn't got you oh my god once your
squad got sick and tired of you
snitching once your your squad got sick
and tired of you lying once your squad
got sick and tired of you over charging
once your squad got sick and tired of
getting less and paying more they
realize you know what let's go over
there they ain't gonna have that money
to fund these wild Endeavors to block we
can't we have to admit father a attic
Final Fantasy series seven remake we
thought that Jake was coming up coming
off that one yeah the year came on
everybody where is that so all we see
was was Tifa and Eric's running around
with a new Birkin bag
this is the game this is the game we
play it's it's War it's competition it's
business dude's just gonna do whatever
they got to do to keep that association
with their platform and I get I have to
defend somebody on this one only for the
sense of fact look they paying they
doing whatever they do I just don't like
the secrets I don't like the secret
extended I wish I just knew what it was
up that's that's my only issue for Life
yeah I just wish I knew but that's all
you know at the end of the day you got
to do so because this game pass thing
kid bro it's it's something I mean even
Sony said it
yo even the competition said we have
nothing in the future right now that
could compete with them and if y'all
don't know what nothing looks like it
looks like this
this is what nothing looks like so if
you trying to figure out what they got
that the complete compete with Game Pass
in Call of Duty it looks just like me
and there you have it yeah but that's
what like this is listen I won't say
this um it's funny to see this we rarely
get this information public yeah so it's
cool to see what's really how they
really think about each other on certain
things and yeah the last thing I'll just
say is to me it's the ecosystem battle
that's the last one it's the ecosystem
Sony wants to do the traditional model
the way they've been doing it hallway
sales they don't want to play in this
other game that Microsoft trying to do
and I get it and Microsoft was like nah
fam like don't try to stop us from
competing like there's a part I
completely feel with Microsoft like yo
just because I'm not see this is where
everybody stuff is gonna win
because their model is better for
regulators and Gamers you're giving
Gamers destroy this is better for the
industry and competition somebody's like
now that ain't better for us though
we know this deal going through most
likely you know I'm saying and it's just
funny to see because I said addict
probably on the spot last week and Alex
was like yo what you think maybe the
better long-term I do I just I do think
Microsoft's position for the long game
bet I give you that kick for the for the
cloud play everywhere you know they're
investing in the club they're investing
in believing in this ecosystem and I
can't get mad at them for saying yo this
is our model that we we invent the rules
on this is where it's gonna go and
they're doing a fantastic job on it and
so they recognizes Phil Dominus Maximus
are really expensive and uh oh geek
and I guarantee you if if there were
only five million Game Pass subscribers
right now Sony would not be saying
anything because it wouldn't know it
wouldn't be a problem they do recognize
the market has spoken the market likes
giving getting a lot of games with 15 or
10 a month go figure you see it's only
now follow suit with the PC stuff where
people said they would never do that I
love you anyway moving on that's really
good let's get these super chats
real quick yeah
we got a bunch
we got Dragonheart Yobe TV ten dollars
hashtag peace love life to the Lords and
I always heard through the years uh CEOs
from rival companies always have lunch
with each other and Etc I don't think
Microsoft was only a buddy buddy after
this mess they I mean again none of this
is expected to get out so you know and
the fact of the matter is like I said
they both of them are say Petty things
about one another and a hundred percent
you knew somebody was gonna say
something like this because if they can
help it if there's even a sliver of a
chance that this deal is not gonna go
through they're gonna help do that like
it come on so that that's that was
guaranteed so they're still buddy buddy
you know it is what it is
then we got Lord of roughness two pounds
of the chat Sony snitching don't matter
still no ps6
on that square
um I am about to mangle this name but we
got bargava pot kamuri uh 179 rupees
thank you sir hey Cog did you play
diophil Chronicle demo I don't think any
of us have played it yet have you played
it attic no you don't call it we got
c-mad five dollars Super Chat a point
that's not talked about is that Sony
doesn't own its own infrastructure they
have to pay Microsoft for the user never
played that game so I could do it
that's Microsoft's Checkmate the fact
that Microsoft owns Azure and Sony has
to use Azure I mean again well
they're in bed
you know they're just a disgruntled
that is
he's trying to get unionized
900 of this chat y'all hit the like
button that's cool to see then we got
flame to a lot of Super Chat this Melvin
situation is very specific are you okay
yo remember that dude I danced with
bigger dudes
I remember that I remember that fight
Sony I never did why are you afraid just
take the Fate
that was the Einstein that was the odd
style fight yeah yeah that was funny sir
dude sir dude yeah I'll be like bro
don't do it yeah you can stretched out
I'll do it
that's what I knew he was scared I was
like healing he was like you see them
gloves yeah I was like yeah oh yeah yeah
song you was there he was like yo he got
the boxes with his ass for a reason
leave him alone he'll be stretched out
we try to save you
in the end Regulators look out for the
consumer yes they do Sony is asking them
to look out for them Sony has an answer
to how this is bad for the consumer uh
yeah that's a fact and that's where
Microsoft's gonna win because ultimately
yeah somebody said well well the hell
with this consumers
that you're right that you're right
and we got splendiferous two dollars
ain't calling no names but Phil want to
buy air things
there we got gamer by choice five
dollars for chat my question did the
other Regulators ask this question and
Sony answered the same but Brazil is the
one we heard about if so Xbox has right
to Clarity I think Brazil is just the
only one with the the the least amount
of security
the leaks happen in Brazil
I can't
who on the panel wants to tackle this
your Sony what's your argument that the
Microsoft uh Activision Blizzard King
deal is bad for the consumer Sony hasn't
answered this yet that is correct
there's there is no answer to that yeah
the only the only argument Sony ever has
in in terms of what Microsoft is doing
would be the fact that game pass is
something that they can't compete with
that they can't do the same thing that
is the only the and the cloud
infrastructure stuff that is it talking
about how it affects them and not the
consumer right and if you know they
actually look over to Sony and see their
their business practices are not
consumer friendly they might have their
own inquiry going on over there so take
a little Anti-Trust going on forcing you
guys to pay extra for something that
they marketed like dual sense controls
how you gonna be the focal point or
something but you're gonna pay extra for
that the problem the problem is is
you know even with uh Microsoft
requiring Activision they're still not
the biggest people in the game yeah
it's just like you can't really come out
there with a sob story when you're still
above the people after they bought it
and you know what else they say Call of
Duty is so influential but at the same
time Nintendo switch is out here as the
double platform and PC and they don't
have Call of Duty most don't have Call
of Duty they still existing so you can't
say it it's that influential when the
the people who are dominated Market
don't even have Call of Duty on any
platform right and it's still
influential and you're saying this all
the while knowing that the game is still
coming to your platform yep you can't
lawyers go lawyer conference
we got split difference five dollar
Super Chat still
I don't care what nobody want to say I
remember when I wasn't in charge and
Sean Layton beat the pants off my
console well I'm in charge now what up
Jim
absolutely this is crazy and we'll be
given quote quote from the great uh
yes absolutely then we got bags sold in
the park I want in yeah
five dollars of a chat shout out to Carl
getting that last red border oh yeah
done and getting the conflux challenge
done on Master by the way got that
Master Templar CP for you there's got to
be yo ducky salute to you man appreciate
the help had so much fun me and you was
holding that side down on the conflicts
and you was holding me down salute to
that and uh yeah we'll do the Templar
and I actually do gotta run vial again
so I might be on tonight I don't know if
I'm going out so I might be on today so
let me know
then we got pragmatic Eagle two dollars
Super Chat allowing cross play three
years ago would have avoided this I
don't know they would have avoided it no
yeah I mean it I mean it might have
helped
it might have helped in terms of people
feeling like that whatever it might have
helped in that people feel that the that
the core console or or ecosystem for
Call of Duty is x-platform or it's
Playstation or Xbox if anything that
helps PlayStation because it doesn't
make it to where look even if that goes
on the other platform in their marketing
they're not you could still play with
your friends over there because there's
no single down on one console right it's
not locked down yeah none of these
arguments hold any water it's just funny
to see the decision
what
where's the gun it's back home in his
locker
combination is 13 13 14.
continue
supplying context according to King they
would just Supply contact oh okay
[Music]
they mad disrespectful no then we got
Spartan go 17 two pair of Super Chat the
only thing keeping Sony Alive Now is
Microsoft oh my God this is true wow
they go down there and shut off some
service wow
then we got Mr blt's two dollars King is
spot on with that Sony is on the defense
yeah okay
then we got Sparta goes together two
pound Super Chat yesterday's price is
not today's price
shout out to Fat Joe The Tesco this is
Luke then we got Dorian Gray five
dollars for chat competition is building
a better mousetrap not breaking the
other guy's mouth trap why can't so many
this is what king wants thinking about
this complete Annihilation
why can't Sony give us more what
happened oh drama okay cool no I did
something like it was like it sounded
like a train but it was like really
close uh
[Laughter]
why can't Sony give us more not take
away from them that is that is true this
is what I say vote with your dollars
people don't give don't give more money
for them to do this blocking that
they're doing
let me see a lot of people go back a
little bit we got a couple of more
um
yeah it was Dorian Grace's hard geek
yeah I get to need twenty dollars I
think Microsoft was pointing out
PlayStation has contracts to keep games
from Game Pass and other subs not
marketing deals might be okay against
Xbox but consider stadia Aluna that
can't get those games either might be
anti-competitive and that's the thing
it's about being anti-competitive when
you start doing things like that where
you're keeping it off of other platforms
especially when you think about a
stadium or Luna and the argument might
be stronger Stadium lunar had a stronger
standing in the in the in gaming the
argument would be hey you're keeping
those games off of these platforms whose
bread and butter is that that is the
only way you get games there so you know
it behooves them that stadia and Luna
are as strong as they are
then we have Mandingo Mexican for 20 of
a chat King crit Christie heart says
that if Microsoft pulls Cod from
PlayStation then Sony will pull their
games so I ask in what reality do the
Sony games in Game Pass measure up to
Cod Chrissy doesn't understand Sony has
no control of over MLB and Destiny yeah
he said Sony will pull again yeah
first of all Christopher Hart Destiny
Bungie already told you
all right she told you before you even
signed a contract whatever you was gonna
do she gonna do what she wants she like
us all right so she like it over here so
you not exclusive even when you paid for
it we don't care you're gonna share you
share that girl
all right
now that you know you in an open
relationship with her okay
MLB the Show told you MLB told you
she not exclusive either and either you
either you treat her right and let her
go wherever she won't go and do whatever
she want to do which is go over the game
pass and hang out over there at the
Microsoft mansion
or or you have to give her up entirely
you said no I love her too much
and I must share that girl so you in two
open relationships that you can't get
out of because you can't lose either one
of them so this is where your money
don't work over here baby
yeah it was a fire fire retort if I get
it then we got C mad five dollars to
protect so in the end Microsoft ABK deal
goes through what does Sony do next are
they then forced to go day and date
nah they won't no they will never
and not yet give me an app I think the
bungee deal was was a part response I
always feel that yeah
uh then we got Spartan go 17 two pound
Super Chat stop he's already dead that's
all I'm hearing salute
then we have
once again
we got yeah yeah okay that was it that
was it all right let's move on here we
go
all right so yeah new uh fact on Sony's
website hints that PC ports of
PlayStation games may require a PSN
account at some point in the future
shout out to video games chronicle.com
so it looks like there's a section on
the official PlayStation website
dedicated to PC games contains some
specific information about people
looking to get their titles of steam at
Epic store and it says that
um regarding trophy support for PC games
they will not sync with your trophy list
on your PSN profile other others include
the word currently implying that the
situation has the potential to change it
says no you currently do not need a PSN
account to enjoy PlayStation uh Studio
games on PC and it says the site also
says it's currently not possible to
transfer save data from the PS5 or PS5
PS4 or PS5 version of a PlayStation
Studios game to the PC version so um
yeah this is the latest information you
know what I mean or reference to this
account that's King wanted to bring to
the attention of the the round table sir
so your thoughts on this sir wow very
well well
look to who we have here doing more
anti-consumer stuff
let me tell you
they let you try those bars they was
like yeah eat that you like what Nixon's
is serving up yeah
wouldn't you like to get a platinum foil
[Laughter]
right oh your community can't see that
oh man yo people over at PlayStation
they don't know that you actually got
all that stuff in God of War done
you know the hardest difficulties you
got all those Valkyries got that
Platinum they can't see that
well currently at the moment right now
that's not possible but in the future
you're gonna have to pay fast
we'll be in your pockets soon enough
lying that this is a predecessor to
charging for PSN accounts integration
what I'm saying is
they told you the bill is coming they
just didn't tell you how much
and these two
known for this they know for giving you
something and then coming right they
double right back on your head and make
you pay for that same stuff uh that's
supposed to be
in there initially like what do you
think if it's a PlayStation game and it
has the platinums it has all that stuff
and you purchase this game over here
that that stuff will automatically link
to your account and then it will pop up
that oh you did do this on the hardest
mode
why must you gotta go double Platinum
why did why do you gotta go do double
work and I'm pretty sure I'm empathizing
and sympathizing Sony fan that right now
your platinums can't be seen by your
team and you want that to be seen and
Sony hears you but you're gonna have to
pay for that
where did they say you have to pay for
that it's gonna say that
they ain't giving you nothing for free
they ain't never gave you anything you
have to pay for dual sets something
that's there so just to just sign on
your PSN account now requires it
requires the money okay hey you have to
pay for the SSD too
stuff that's an innate in the system
they want you now now they gonna say it
and they're gonna be like hey wouldn't
it be cool to let your friends know what
you're doing over here in the PC World
that you paid this 75 for this game for
yeah it would be great well Pony up 25
and the world can know what you did too
uh I said so you're implying that this
is coming this is yeah it's coming and
I'm always right 97
interesting I just brought this to the
crew I just wanted to see if you think
Tony gonna make them pay too addict your
thoughts on this sir
it is what it is I am
it's just like the PC talks I I think's
getting a little bit um
yeah
it's not that it's just like we've been
talking about the PC and Playstation
guys going to PC like you know I I will
say that I don't know exactly it was the
that's fantastic people were telling me
the PC Port was like crashing all the
time no not not I mean I played it I
didn't have any issues I didn't have
issues with crashing yeah people that's
what I was seeing on maybe maybe it just
some people's rigs couldn't handle it I
don't know uh but it is what it is I'm
glad people got that you know I'll never
play that on the pieces
he's got a 30 60. yeah yeah and a 5900
like I don't know wow you gotta break
this down the only way you get me on PC
is if I had to review a game on PC
literally okay because you're literally
not playing the best version of the game
even on your PS5 you're you're skipping
out yourself he is consistent he don't
like that you don't like Masterpiece
it's not even that it's just like look
if the game runs fine I don't care about
none of that Logistics stuff I don't
care about a widescreen no one Tinker
this stuff's cute it's just yeah
I'm not playing troubleshoot games
I'm not sitting there people are like I
remember smooth was having some issues
uh because he he was having like
stuttering and stuff and people was
calling me like you know jumping a
Discord to fix them like nah I'll go
play that on Playstation
I'm not gonna stay here though I'm not
making a second job on diagnostic games
to play it on yeah
but my question is
to King's Point do you think they will
integrate PSN accounts and to King's
Point do you think they will charge if
they do
uh they'd be stupid to charge the place
uh the PC thing because what I will say
about you know PC consumer base is uh
you don't play with them like because
they will they have their own little
cancer culture going on over there so
you know uh if if you do do that song
you don't put no reviewing process on
your stuff because it's going to get
review bombed uh that I will say a lot
of the PC people are act like children
if they don't get everything they want
they act like oh I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna pirate your stuff and I don't get
that mindset
but don't you like with the PC community
no I don't yeah first off you guys
expect your build Edition
my build and shut up
you need they have to
have to shoot that 30 80 that 30 90.
that 30 80 I got to spend 50 minutes in
the settings to to get ready properly
like there's just two there's too many
variables on PC and people in the chat
will sit there and say oh addicts that's
not how it works tell me how one time I
spent an hour trying to diagnose while
my controller wasn't working with my my
PC like no we ain't gonna sit here and
act like I've had these issues I've had
mad issues with Destiny Destiny would
just be like completely shutting off for
no reason multiple times I've had issues
with cheaters oh my God go in show me
the bill they will cheat and Among Us
they will cheat
oh guys
you'll be sitting there you'll be
thinking you're doing good you've been
thinking about the windows and you look
up and and there's someone floating at
the top of the screen
like it's just like look like even if
you get like I could maybe I can get by
fact that every you know what's funny
the fact that people expect a bare
minimum when it comes to people oh it's
it's on our platform okay okay it's on
our platform or if it doesn't function
correctly you know we'll fix it we'll
fix it for you that's fine no they I get
it there's a lot of variables a lot of
graphics cards I don't care you don't
want them to show you they built show
your Billy Bogey and shirt is up in the
stores right now go get that go get that
show me your bill if you want it let's
see what I'm showing the feeling that's
funny you know what's funny people sit
there and they'll say I it's so bad in
the PC Community they're not all these
PCS you you cap because I've seen a few
of you say well you know what I'm I'm a
pirate at the game first to see if it
works and then if it works correctly
then I'm gonna buy it so you gotta
pirate again to make sure that your
money's right let me make make that make
sense please make that make sense
at the people that say that oh I don't
like Nintendo games so I'm gonna make it
I I'm gonna download an emulator and I'm
a pirate
their decisions I don't support their
decisions and then I'll just sit there
and I'm like well I'm sorry guys but you
triggered my trap
it makes no sense if you don't support
the company don't support the company
even by giving them your time people
don't act like time is a resource time
is more important than money
this this has to be a regular segment
with addict show me
it's just it just it just annoys me that
people sit there and they hype up this
this PC brand they sit there and they
say oh this is amazing Spider-Man came
out in 2018. it's 20 22.
um no was it 19 or 18 one of them did
God war came out I think earlier this
year didn't it yeah last year that came
out in 2018. slow-mo said emulation too
slow motion emulation is the wave
demolition is the wave yeah distilling
way so what happens when they come out
day and day together then what so yeah
that's cool then you're gonna accept
having the inferior version uh do I
already accepted
yeah
120 stuff and stuff like that I was
playing stuff on it a 920 a 920. an RTA
and people was like Nabi you gotta you
gotta upgrade that and I'm good no you
got it like I don't care like as long as
it boots up it's functional and ain't no
cheaters
I respect it I respect go off at it show
them your bills
the knee on performance I said that but
when you go sit here and act like every
person or it's like every person when I
was playing Destiny was cheating you
know obviously that's exact right but
you go into Trials of Osiris on PC it
was cheaters
people getting shot through walls yo
okay I'm gonna stop so I'm gonna go play
Fall Guys people floating through the
map okay I'm gonna stop cause I'm gonna
play Among Us people are are using mods
where you could they could see who the
Imposter is
I'll go back to Xbox
you know what they said hockey said it
yo they loving to show me your build
Emoji it's up there t-shirt it's up now
go get that show you
I'm upset because I'm looking at the the
animation man someone's gonna tell this
man to take this PC off of this app but
that's what makes it perfect that's
where it comes from it makes it perfect
no if anything you need to show my
Avatar behind it like breaking it right
I have an issue with the PC platform
it's mainly the community of people oh
damn man we going after the whole
community
we doing it explain to me how everyone's
sitting there like at it I just switch
games man you know the 30 frames I don't
like them but the steam deck does it
it's okay oh okay okay so so this is the
revenge for the switch team I bet you if
you put Steam before that Nintendo
switch people will be popping up there
so you said they was capping when it was
30 frames and they were going in on
switch and out of the Steve deck and
some of them gays are still 30 frames
but Nintendo games we're running 60 on
the steam day that's for sure that's 100
sure okay but those same people are
saying that they won't play anything
that's below 60 but they don't mind if
it's a steam deck the pirate Nintendo
games because it's bad performance
games on Steam deck make it make sense
attic always bases his arguments and
opinions on the worst of the worst of
the community like that's fun because
they do that to me so I'ma throw that
right back at
I sit there all week on Twitter with my
hand in the air and they just give me
all that bad karma and I'm making it the
most illest Black Spirit Bomb knowing
the man
and I'm a captain every Sunday I can't
look and there you have it Attic in the
PC Community show me your build segment
bro
Lord addict go get there yeah slo-mo I'm
stereotyping all of you guys together
he put y'all onto the box and that there
it is so um look
account I don't know we went left
I mean listen uh Xboxes I mean if you
play Xbox games on Steam you get your
you know you get your achievements so
but you can get a Microsoft account for
free so I I like addicts then it would
be very stupid to go and charge people I
know where King is getting this
information from I'm getting it from
track record
about hey they have been nickel and
Diamond people yeah they told you we're
going to continue to Nick and dime you
they'll stop asking about this ten
dollar upgrade you're gonna pay that and
that's it I get it so
yes as a company
or would I put it past them to try to
nickel and die me and try to do
something so why not
um PC delegation does not recognize
Attica his slandered today that's fine
that's fine because I'm not at your
front door is asking to come in I'm
breaking through with bombs addicts
those violence today I'm sorry let me
jump protocol Dory agree to a lot of
Super Chat like like like not liking PC
hurts us one less peasant wow you've
been deemed a peasant sir hold on Forte
I'm with attic trials has was a cheater
Haven on us we ain't gonna act like we
wasn't trying to leave PC in the test
with the destiny 2 up there look I give
you the cheat I give them that look let
me get let me tell the Chad a little bit
of a story you know I'll come in there
called like I gotta I got a a solution
to our PC cheating ways what's that
cause subscribe
like okay I'm leaving playing State how
is it stadia it's more popping because
of cheaters than the actual platform
that it originated from how is it that I
have to go to a streaming service that
is dead to get off the one that isn't
dead
we did do that because the cheat was
that bad that's y'all fault but trying
to play multiplayer games
that's just stupid like yeah so you
admit there's a problem with cheating
there's been a problem for 50 years yeah
but I can understand the bad frustration
that it's a competitive gamer
yeah like you playing four guys and four
guys got their heads or you throwing
your half daddy quit playing fall guys
because there was too many cheating laws
what they do it in four guys no okay so
there's this map I remember you guys
remember it where like the tiles
disappeared yeah yeah so there was a
dude that didn't move he was at the top
and everyone and me and Cat Daddy are at
the bottom and we just woke up below my
and I fell off and I was like cat daddy
you got this and then I like a pushed
right bumper and I went over and I saw
some dude floating like cat daddy miles
to just drop you ain't winning you ain't
gonna win he had he had the code to stay
in the area you know okay the PC is the
single players yes see that's my soft
sensibilities advice because he don't he
don't got it he ain't gotta deal with
that he played a single player games the
fact that you played a single player
games apart from the PC and that's
really Sony because you talked about all
the Sony stuff this weekend let's just
say all of the stuff that you were
playing and you got these achievements
wouldn't it be nice that they actually
transferred over to your place oh yeah I
would love to absolutely absolutely and
for a small fee that will be optional
for you later because you know like I
know okay
and and this is how we can get the real
answer out of uh straddle defense solve
oh God this is how we get the real land
let's go
Would You Bet Your Life that Sony's
gonna give us free hell no wait thank
you so in order we know that Sony's
gonna make you pay
and let's stop acting like there's a
possibility because it's not because
he's not gonna bet his life
I am of the mind that they would be
stupid to do so I wouldn't necessarily
put a pastor though look my ball is
gonna be quick on this um because I just
killed this up it was hilarious yeah I
just think that look they got to worry
about the infrastructure first before
they try to put things in that in the PC
space on an account level I want it yes
because now that I'm using the steam
deck more it's become a PlayStation
Portable for me and I love it I want the
trophies I want that that thing the
beautiful thing about some of the Xbox
games that Steam games that require the
Xbox account that's free from you know
you get some of that synchronization you
know what I mean with the achievements
of the steam joint popping so I would
love that because you got your credit
and it that's that was my only
trepidation song from from quote unquote
downloading the bangers on Steam deck
like damn I ain't gonna get no trophy
for this no trophies you know what I'm
saying but then when I thought about I
was like look but at least I'm going to
be finishing games getting more games
done right on the go because you know
our schedules and we travel so I made
that that sacrifice so to speak and what
is I had this conversation with Colin
in regards to Xbox because he was just
like look I would play on the Xbox
ecosystem way more if there was a way
from for the third party games the
trophies to carry over so I came up with
this thing like smart you know
achievements or smart delivery smart
onboarding I call it smart onboard I was
like if XBox had a thing called smart
onboarding right and then a Sony guy
says okay you know you ain't gonna get
the exclusive trophies because they
don't have that over there but every
third party game you play in the minute
you log into your Xbox with that profile
and it pops up that's incentive so I
think it would be cool if yeah like if
steam had that with PlayStation trophies
mean a lot to the PlayStation Community
if they had that yeah yeah to King's
points mean a lot yeah absolutely to
King's Point I don't know look I I can't
play Peppa because I I will give King
this like if it did come out that would
be wild if they tried to charge though
because it feels like it feels like you
know what it is and this makes sense
the work that it would take to do that
right on the back end
they would maybe try to justify that oh
that that that yeah that pertains to the
middle tier of PS Plus or whatever yeah
I can see it I could definitely I could
see it I could see it or even the bottom
tier because that bottom tier PS plus
you're still paying for PS plus so it's
not like a straight up free PSN account
and that's it yeah I could see that them
justifying like all the work that's
going to go into making that happen you
know what king maybe right linking in
PlayStation Plus premium or the PC
service kind of thing and then it's like
okay this High yeah because they'd be
like if you want this you subscribe to
us because let's say they really Embrace
PC like how Game Pass has a PC game pass
yeah and they have a PC kids right it
could happen in that way that I could
say Nixa shout out to Nixon
[Music]
like 40 FPS you still don't really
notice it on that small screen it's
still on a small screen yeah so what I
did I did the 40 and then but what I did
was okay I said how does this improve
over the PlayStation core experience
right and when you look at the the
street level stuff like for me having
New York feel alive is What mattered the
most right the density so I increase the
density of the population to the city
feel alive for the buildings to sort of
feel alive so and so that
coupled with that 40 FPS and the MSR and
all that time do you have uh variable
rate setting on off no rapid rate
shading I use for um pixel based games
this is what attic hey yeah
so he like if y'all don't get on with
this troubleshooting on his face okay
get go off at it go ahead show us all
this talk all this talk on this average
handheld things about playing this
average game
average Spiderman damn
the only good thing about that
Spider-Man game was the credits at the
end wow oh I think you know what it is I
think because it is this when you won
that um
I've never been a big fan of the average
game oh you always found Spider-Man you
got videos on my YouTube channel saying
how average like yeah you've been
consistent with you yeah yeah okay but
that's all I got to say we have to
disagree
but but shout out to nixes because this
is and I remember when I said
Spider-Man's gonna be the first game
King was like nah they don't need it
yeah they need it can I tell you this
right now who did that for you yeah was
it was it their first game yes that no
was it who's first game was that Nixon's
first game on the PlayStation yes yeah
was it no yes it was so this is
who did the god of war in the um the
earlier ports were I forgot PC Master
races who did what's nixus's first point
I think they helped out on
PCS
who what was Nixon's Furniture
days gone so they say days gone Lucius
augustus's day gone
one very well that was hold on
you got the Google
he said they fixed
visuals although this port was mainly
handled by Canadian Studio jetpack
interactive original creators at Santa
Monica Salma you're more than welcome to
pull up here next week to okay so no so
this is Nixon's first game oh man you so
you were right
so days ago was it mixes because that's
what Lucius is saying real quick slow mo
you're more than welcome to pull up here
next week to defend yourself do I go
meet next week it was on PC port
nope
you're still talking about this PCS
out of Haven did it out of here so he
baby so I was right maybe it was yes
you're right all right yeah okay I mean
think about it took him a couple of
years right yeah to get this down this
Googling stuff is pissing me off but I'm
gonna tell y'all right now the expertise
that they have
and you know the port is that good
because of the scalability of the poor
the scalability of the port is kind of
ridiculous and they implement it from
what I've seen shout out to digital
Foundry you know I gotta give y'all some
respect y'all actually showing y'all the
the best version of the game played on
the PC
I want to play that game really with the
Dual sense controller go to the PC
you're not gonna have any achievements
though
um but um
that's coming later yes
uh what I'm not gonna lie that game
looks phenomenal phenomenal if you
remember how great it is yeah I saw some
Ultra widescreen gameplay
yeah next topic was super chats and uh
thing uh let me I got a few more to copy
yeah let's get this is going to be a
very short next Stacks to a bang bang
bang boogie hold on you can actually
combine them I have to scroll back put
them together there's only two of them
did it yeah yeah exactly
I'm looking for Mike
I still ain't said
you just you waited till the morning of
to remind someone
got a gift from Lord cyber be it
sovereign
this is not real
oh no yo they loving this show with your
bill on Twitter Saturday go check out
IOP Twitter all right
I hope I didn't miss anything here we
got okay flame two dollar Super Chat yes
attic there are Destiny cheaters even
even bungee then we have we roll back we
got Mandingo mcstickins two dollar Super
Chat Black Spirit Bomb that sounds
powerful yeah
[Music]
been playing Spider-Man on Steam deck
deck is fire yes it is and it is and it
and it does feel like it's going to
catch fire as well yeah it does feel you
gotta be careful yeah
mental five dollars Super Chat PC stands
for players cheating wow
jetpack interactive help with the PC
Port of God oh so one of King's ghouls
pulled up on me yo yeah he said yeah he
said so he got some document and he said
the publisher who made the marketing
game with Sony has to ensure a Content
feature and Technical parity technical
parody is subject to platform
limitations and means that other
platforms cannot Implement technologies
that go beyond technical limitations of
the PlayStation platform we have some
documents yo for his King they got the
he got the statement yeah listen listen
article 1.4 Shadow broker damn yeah I
just I just I just linked you in there
though that shout out shout out
I gotta retweet that okay he got the
evidence so we'll solve I think I think
you messed up
think you send it to somebody oh no no
anyway
I think you missed some super chats too
no I haven't I haven't copy pasted it
don't work then we got Donald ten
dollars we could chat addict is speaking
nothing but fact today Spider-Man was a
disappointment no at the PC garbage
Community is garbage wow David still has
had the same BS since the 90s and the
steam deck is a novelty at best I got no
issue wow like look Panda I have issues
with the contradicting the PC Community
has and some of them I feel like are
they act like eight-year-olds but I have
a lot of friends that play on that
platform but you guys like to contradict
yourself it's like you're chasing your
toe all day I like to show me your build
has a beat while he's talking
there we go back slap two dollar Super
Chat I got no problems playing
multiplayer games on PC get good because
you're cheating too
my truck
we got Kay Johnson the five dollar Super
Chat I need that diagnostic gaming
t-shirt and women's medium thank you
baby girl
girl it's up there no she needs a
diagnostic game hold a diagnostic Game
Attic bar today we got Raider blade five
dollar Super Chat um hey question if
Sony pays to block would they pay to
block release games that that they have
the marketing for if
to give or assist their games like God
of War don't really understand the
question
would they pay to block release games
that they have marketing for
if to assist their own games like God of
War
okay when they pay to block games that
have a release already block games off
Game Pass yeah
yeah I mean if you could just in the
chat just kind of clarify what you're
gonna say yeah you got to clarify that
mm-hmm all right let me see that's it
all right so final two topics we will
combine these bad boys soft addict this
is you solve to start with you first so
what you've been playing some things man
what games you've been playing yeah
I played a little bit I think it's
probably played more than me but uh yeah
so Cult of the Lamb
is uh gotta cut you uh our geek should
he actually explained he said he think
he means like forespoken that they move
that to next year to make space for God
of War oh yeah it's possible I mean they
already did it with uh for spoken yeah
more spoken is done pretty much it's
just not you know it doesn't really it's
not releasing it on purpose oh okay all
right continue so yeah what's going on
so yeah so Cult of the Lamb is the
latest game from massive monster pause
uh privileged by devolver digital as
king said King and Gene had seen this
game a while back and put it all of us
on to this
um so it is basically part roguelike
part sort of uh like uh what is it like
management Sim where basically the
premise of it is that you are you are
the proverbial sacrificial lamb and you
uh you are sacrificed in by four Elder
gods in order to prevent uh prophecy
that's supposed to come true that the
fifth elder god which they have sort of
uh they have him chained up and captured
apparently he's really bad so there's a
prophecy that you would be the one to
bring this back to life yeah something
from your race so they're killing all of
your race right so what they don't
realize is that by by sacrificing you
they actually put you closer to this
fifth elder god and what happens is that
this elder god brings you back to life
and with the condition that you start a
cult in his name so this cute little
lamb now has to start a culture today
of this fifth Elder guy would say the
only code they only call him the one
that Waits below or something like that
but you get the impression it's the
devil basically yeah
so the gameplay is basically you uh
going out into the world trying to
defeat these other four Elder Gods
um and in the process create your cult
in the name of this fifth elder god
right
um and it's again it's it is so Charming
it is like the art style is hilarious
because you're doing all this demonic
crazy things
these cute looking characters like and
and the gameplay your mileage is going
to depend on how much you like the the
the what you call the Management's in
part of it because the combat part of it
is is great but it isn't it isn't deep
like a Hades or or
um what you call it uh dead cells it
isn't deep like that the the bulk of the
game is you bringing up your cult right
and the fun part about bringing up the
cult is that so you have to provide
everything for them it's basically you
have to provide food shelter you have to
make maintain them since they're animals
they're pooping all over the place you
gotta clean up the pool right and the
thing about it is if you don't manage
them well they're going to start
dissenting against you right so when you
start dissenting then you have to do
things to bring them back in the fall
and it's so sometimes that that requires
them up like so this is the thing
I'll have this go ahead and uh
I got to take my green screen effect off
um uh go ahead and show this and uh I'll
show them what uh competitive well until
you bring it back so yeah so then the
thing is like the funniest part to me so
far is that part where how do you manage
your cult because again you have to be
on top of it when it comes to hey man
we're hungry they're always freaking
hungry hey we need shelter hey um you
know um this thing has to be built you
need to build you need to build like a
like a church for you to be able to
preach to them and all this stuff the
word and this demon god all of of this
stuff that you have to do and the thing
about it is it's one of those things
where you have to be on top of it goes
what's going to happen is you're going
to get to the centers right so then when
once you get to the centers it's one of
those things where it's like okay
I have to be I have to bring them more
of the stuff they need or this is
satanic edible crust and that's what it
is
it like you got your your basic Road
features like there's a room here where
like you know increase chances to spawn
better chests exactly the funny things I
had to start the game over because I got
like six seven hours in and I and it's
when I it's when you call a [ __ ] the
other night when you called yes I didn't
pause it so when I came back all my
people were dead so I had a reason he
wasn't feeding them okay yeah cause it
was just sitting there I like I guess
like unless you like physically pause it
the game's gonna keep running in the
back like the simulation aspect of it
yeah so so the thing is right once
they're dissenting right and they and
they're unhappy you can do things to
make them happy right or you can show
your strength by a couple of different
things like Addie said you could lock
them up right and you can scare your
other your other followers into like
into submission and you're like listen
man this is what's going to happen to
you right you can also murder some of
your dissenters in front of your other
cultures and let's go for anybody move
that down with the church
who's the master showed up now kiss
myself
so mind you this is all happening under
the guys in this very cute land
now murdering cultists in order for the
rest of the cultists to get in line now
sometimes it could happen that like like
Alex said his whole cult died it can
happen that you don't take care of your
cult enough they all become dissenters
and you have to murder all of them and
start over Jesus right so if you love
that management aspect and that minutia
that is in there and because it's all in
Disguise of these
cute little animals doing this demonic
stuff it to me it was very engaging
whereas in another game for me that much
management Sim wouldn't be so much fun
but um the only thing I wish about the
game is that the combat stuff were more
varied and and in the sense that it
doesn't really feel like like you know
when you play Hades king or when you
play dead cells part of the Allure is
how far can I go how far can I go that
isn't the case here in this thing that's
talking to me is like one of the gods
that wants you that wants you dead yeah
so like they're always coming in and
like talking smack to you and everything
because like they they know that you
that you ain't supposed to be alive and
they uh they're like well the prophecies
already starting to come through so the
only thing we could do at this at this
point is we just have to kill them
instead of it he said no man stir dinner
no no man said you gotta assert that
lamb dominance
[Laughter]
I
thought sir I like it I think uh I think
it's a stand-up type of game I I am kind
of like not necessarily with this game
but I am getting a little bit of fatigue
on roguelike games
um if I were to put a game that this
game reminds me of it's more
moonlighters than like Hades and stuff
because the moonlighters has similar
stuff even like the the doors at the
beginning yeah if you guys uh go back
you'll see like before I came in here I
went into a door it's got five doors so
I I don't know but I assume the dude
that you go unlock you're gonna fight uh
part of me feels like that I don't know
yet oh yeah I think about it but again
the story wise it kind of feels like
once you get to the end you're so
powerful that you're like nah I don't
need you dude I have a feeling that's
what's gonna happen yeah okay well it
looks absolutely hilarious it's so crazy
because you know well man Kyle didn't
get a chance to play yeah you didn't
know we wouldn't know though our opinion
of it you know it doesn't matter this is
based on this I don't know about it even
though uh you know Gene and I very
important
spilled our blood on the floor verbally
uh that's what you need to actually
getting this I love the colors of the
red that's being used uh this game
really has a visual Splendor if it's not
coming across on the screen right now
when you actually have it in person the
game artistic style visual sound effects
everything about this game is really
done well and it's very unique so if you
know uh Gravity Falls and if you've seen
Gravity Falls it's along that line in
that art style in that comedic humor
yeah and I honestly because when I was
talking to the guy at the devolver
digital about this game I was like yo so
is Gravity Falls uh inspiration to this
game because I do see a couple of things
that come from that and he couldn't
really say yeah or no but you know that
uh it was definitely inspired because it
has to be if you if you see Gravity
Falls a lot of the symbolisms and stuff
that's in there I'm not saying satanic
stuff but the cult as aspect of it is
funny and it's taken from there so yeah
so as you can see if your mother walks
in the room yeah while you're playing
this game tell her
and you're not really being demonically
possessed that but let them know that
this is an actual game has a
light-hearted uh Little Lamb who
actually runs a cult
as you could see like I just snatched
like when you defeat bosses because they
pretty much turn into like demons and
stuff like you pretty much take that
boss uh and you're like look like now
come join my coat oh do what I want them
to do yeah so you take that boss you
take them back
[Music]
this game gets deep like as you can see
here like this is to see how he when he
gets on the pulpit to predicate like to
go out and be like well he be teaching
the word
and he elevates
up in the sky
this is the kind of game that when I was
younger I couldn't show like my mom
because yeah this is my video games
yeah this is already think games is for
the devil
definitely like this is the the cult so
like what the cool thing about this game
is like when you take over someone you
can make you can name them what you want
a name you can change their appearance
you get uh like randomize their
appearance wow like
[Music]
no that's nothing look look I can make
them go do stuff go go go worship for me
go worship go collect some wood go uh go
do this for me look how they put their
hands
here's the worship thing that the song
he got the book oh he got the book of X
he got the book of X y'all because he
spreading the word
and then that's how you like you level
up your health like you know Health more
Health look at them flowing in the air
I'm sorry for the people that are
listening at
um Audio Only You have to watch the
video but the YouTube Yo YouTube's lit
gotta see it if you haven't seen what
Cult of the laminate this is ridiculous
eggs
[Applause]
yo yo I I mean devolver just came on
fire their eyes their eye for games
dance around the flame to increase the
size I'm done with this yeah
you're gonna want this on Steam dick
right yeah
that'll gave us yet no Game Pass
no matter fact
um runs real nice
yeah yeah it runs really nice on the
Xbox
all right give me the Xbox
it is a perfect portable game though
clearly someone wants me to play this no
no but you can play it on a cloud though
that's all that's true yeah because you
should be able to stream it right yeah
you should be I have to set that up but
anyway yeah you put it on Xbox we'll
figure it out if not I really like it
I'll just buy it or what you call it but
yeah
um Gerald back says
not having that if she saw that oh yeah
I was not winning that argument that
that would be turned off something cool
said this is the devil addict Mama
addict
because I like when I was collecting
Yu-Gi-Oh cards when I was like 12 13 my
my cousin boiled them because she said
that they were Adidas yeah remember you
said that they boiled your Yu-Gi-Oh
cards and what's funny is if you look at
the value of those cards I had probably
two 300 cars oh that's crazy that's
crazy
so uh other game uh addict are we
combining now because I think we did
talk about Spidey pieces we've got to
talk about this too much Sinister wants
to know because he's fortnite on the
topic that I would release like
just I honestly feel like fortnite might
be one of the most influential if not it
most influenced game that's that's in
history like over Call of Duty over all
these games like look I'm not saying
Call of Duty didn't do a lot for its
time but fortnite is just crazy it's
still going strong still the number one
play game almost on all platforms uh
it's done the most with like mainstream
Dragon Ball Naruto they're throwing
Marvel like I've never seen another game
do this like get like at this point
fortnite isn't a game it's a platform
yeah it's no longer a game it's extended
past that he said it said no builds is
where it's at you know what's crazy
how mad people play fortnite that's all
I play
um and it's and it's kind of crazy it
started off as a bonding thing with um
you know me and my son and
then I become a slave to the season pass
and
I'm gonna tell you it's all consuming
yeah because every time you go into the
the store
right now they have the Silver Surfer up
they have ghost Friday they have noon
nights at the Black Panther and I had to
make a hard choice right because I had
all these v-bucks staved up from the
season pass but I had to make a hard
Choice am I gonna go with Ghost Rider
Silver Surf for or Moon night well Moon
Knight's right there he's one of my
favorite characters and the fact that
um they did such a great job on Disney
plus I was like I really love the
character I really love the outfit that
they did put there they gave you two
switch out stuff and I was like damn man
and I got it so right now I'm grinding
real hard so I can get more money up so
I can go get our Surfer surface and I
know you brought them straight up but
see I can't be justifying I because I'm
a hypocrite I can't be sitting there
keep throwing 24 here in 20 but they
have a model that's if you don't have
self-control right go get that this game
literally can drain the hell out of you
and you feel so good while it's draining
I I've I've I've not seen a game
do this and they they got a the proper
Cadence first of all is using Unreal
Engine five
um
yep oh okay so you see you have the ray
tracing water you have all this stuff
the transparencies you have the
destructibility and then today for no
reason well yesterday this weekend
they have a spaceships in the game for
no reason every every time you go in and
play it's something different and I was
like what is the spaceship oh go check
out the spaceship I go check out the
spaceship I can get in a spaceship it
was a dude attacking me with a spaceship
for no reason oh this and riding Hogs
they got so much it's so diverse that
I'm not gonna lie
they took the pub G what however they
robbed them however they robbed them but
they keep elevating and innovating and
this game is an Unstoppable Beast and
I'm with addict I I didn't think it was
gonna happen I talked so much crap about
it I have to keep saying oh yeah we all
bent the knee before and I made
everybody better knee like it's just
it's a beast man and what is it now it's
got Dragon Ball Z characters no this is
Monday on the 16th Dragon Ball Z coming
out they couldn't like smash couldn't
get Goku and they get Goku that's crazy
right wow yeah salute to them they've
done that they like I said it's the most
transformative game I've seen in a long
time I think what makes it even more
unique is the fact that a lot of these
places like Tech and they'll get like
one or two these this game is getting
stuff that's not even gaming related
Marvel NFL I mean they get a Game of
Thrones they put John Cena in the game
yeah like and I saw I knew they was in
when it was like when they did the
Affinity Gallant Daniels was there one
time I was like yo this is crazy every
time yeah every time you think there's
nothing else that they can do like they
they just they they got to be at ideals
I remember when we said that like the
last time because because I've always
been like I'm not the biggest fortnite
fan but I never underestimate for it
yeah and I remember we got into that
huge debate on whether or not Fortnight
is still that Top Dog oh yeah months
later they sucked the whole game in a
black hole Yeah remember that and then
they sucked it into a black hole pause
and then they said the end or something
like that and it was like that for like
four days and then they
re-launched fortnite who else have done
that no one has done stuff like that and
they support the game too 60 frames per
second I remember when they dropped that
like it's just yeah it's abusive shout
out sorry Sinister but my I do
it's something that me and him worked
out in the background uh and you know
shout out to ACG a lot of other people
that are interested in high high quality
statues and um you know Cog is a
purveyor of fine fine Talent so he
definitely got the Silver Surfer and we
did a great unboxing on dcx I mean
that's to experience and share that with
him and it's a character with of um that
was done by Daniel Bell Silver Surfer
he's a huge fan Cog is a huge fan and
for him to have that statue it really
meant a lot to share that moment with
him and stuff so amen absolutely let's
wrap this up
ah you've been ready for a minute he's
like no PC talk no statues no no no I
really have no issue with statute talk
but it's almost 4 30. yeah shout out to
the coach
the Lord's Folly home on a Sunday
salutes legendary so let's do this um
Pole right and we're about to hear yeah
anything else that's it no we haven't
got any more all right cool so okay
with the latest claims but Mark yourself
accusing Sony of paying blocking rights
to developers to keep games off Game
Pass which practice do you most align
with between the two companies the
choices are a buying time exclusive Game
Pass game releases DLC and secretly
extending these deals from other
platforms while it remains in the
Zeitgeist B buying whole Publishers
developers and permanently making them
most of them exclusive to your screen
encryption service C both practices are
fine by me it's called competition or D
I don't care they both playing dirty it
ain't nobody got time for this when I'm
trying to play on one console show out
to everybody in the realm it will be
going up today shout out to the
legendary chat super chats everything
which is crazy salute man really really
cool to see all y'all doing your thing
and I think the DJ Arrows with two
dollar Super Chat two more hours no
no so that's what I got but Lord where
can I find people find you what you got
going on sir
you find me on Twitter at Lord addict
IOP you can also find me on I don't
really do too much on my YouTube channel
anymore like it's just I got so much
stuff going on like I'm probably gonna
be doing a movie here soon maybe I'll
resume that a little bit differently I
appreciate everyone coming through we
had like almost 950 people in here today
uh you know hit that like button 623
likes the podcast yes over beautiful and
we kind of gave you guys like what three
hours and 17 minutes of a podcast dude
and so yeah I definitely you know we
show up here every week you guys are
really generous with the Super Chat
stuff this week uh you know we will be
doing a community stream next uh next
month I I am going to set something up
in the future where uh because you guys
asked for a lot you asked for Marvel
talk you asked for this you asked for
that uh you know we we try to do as much
as we can but we can't realistically do
everything uh so what I'm gonna start
doing is kind of like a season pass you
know we get a certain amount of members
something the next month we if we hit
that goal we'll do up to that point of
that goal is uh you know give you guys a
couple extra things uh you go you most
likely you guys are going to reach out
every uh month just naturally anyway but
we want to give you a little bit more
for uh you know the support you guys
gave I mean you've got like how many
21 members today yeah that's insane you
guys gifted a lot so you guys get your
live uh live Community stream next month
uh obviously we'll probably wrestling is
what it's going to be on it that's right
2K as soon as it says why was the
fortnite topic so short yeah I know
y'all got a rep Marvel
and I played religiously what what I
don't like is the fact that a lot of you
dudes don't be inviting me to play games
like oh am I that's scary listen I'm I'm
five people away from ten thousand
followers let's go so uh uh and I'm I'm
trying to get there and it's been a
fantastic ride getting to that point but
the hell with that part I tell y'all
every week is King David OTW on Xbox
every week but every week I'm playing
Solo in in fortnite every week Sinister
talking all this crap oh
he the one that got me into the crap and
then he the one that ditched me we got
chicken dinner the first game that we
played and and he ditched me since then
um and he talked about oh we need more
fortnite conversation y'all want more
fortnite conversation I could talk about
it if I'm playing with y'all pause but
y'all not playing playing with me pause
so when are y'all gonna get on pause and
and play with me
no doubt you heard it here first there
you go Sinister shout out to my man
Midway monster can't you go to repeat no
it's a good show already yes yes it was
fine most likely I know there's a
destiny raid at the end of the month but
I don't we don't know what raid yet
slo-mo says King when do you play It's
let's Squad up they say I'm all I'm on
all day Stitch call you out says King
offline all the time
DJ Auto's call you out still waiting on
Pub G they calling out check it out
check it out I'm offline all the time
but yet you send me DMS for tick tock
got him facts look at all your tick
tocks that you said give you the tick
tock mask facts
all day you can message me and say
whatever we doing it the factual exactly
so so you're gonna stop for me that's a
sin for you your addict he did what he
triggered what
damn
got it that's how we tag teams let's go
pause
salute to you
what else we got
citizen said no you told me it's just
you and the kid
stop snitching and just getting it fair
enough all right South where can the
five people find you going on sir you
can find me uh playing on my steam deck
you know bring bringing people to the
Flack he showed up that Steve that bill
that episode
all that Tinker in that attic oh that
tinkering going on Steve doing that
um I will be recording in a little while
this week's Lord's minute with Lady
April we're gonna be talking about the
delay of Hogwarts legacies
tell them out didn't that game go for
pre-order
time out didn't they have videos
wait a second
hey tell me the release date of that
what was the release date you tell me
since you know so much
the delay day is there wasn't a release
date it wasn't no but it got delayed
right it got delayed but there wasn't we
saw actual games the same thing did we
see gameplay same thing you saw game
play we haven't released
you could keep hot bend the knee you
[ __ ] the release date look man it
wasn't true yourself but the team was
out there doing the narrative these are
two different scenarios but I don't got
time to argue
hungry all I can say is I saw game play
and I don't see gameplay so I don't
believe them other dudes just putting
out a date they don't make it happen
shout out to Twitch remember going to be
even more sweet it's gonna be longer
shout out to me it was in February Brick
House arsh on Twitch he said shout out
to the twitch chat absolutely over there
did you see what I sent you in the zoom
chat let me check make sure you copy
paste that I will I will sir
[Music]
what you got going on you can find me on
Twitter King David OTW where I'm five
people away from actually
it's dope yeah same King David OTW on
Xbox and uh platforms and on the
PlayStation platform whatever I choose
the surface
is Xbox 360 lover or one yeah but um and
combat talk with the King Saturdays at
10 p.m live uh when there's a relevant
fight I'm not gonna drag you out through
some of the Zone crap
um
unless they have something relevant but
uh this weekend was pretty good teal
FEMA looked great all the people that
came out of support it's very hard to do
a one-man show yeah it is
engaging to actually tell you all what's
going on to actually read the chats and
actually have such a a enthusiasm for at
least two and a half hours but you guys
make it absolutely easy the time flies
by and we have great conversation great
boxing conversation and you guys are so
aware on what's going on and I do love
that level of Engagement uh us guys and
and girls is up late at night and if you
have nobody to talk to you can talk to
me that's what community is about
because we're alone we're doing that
right there man solution no doubt yeah
you're out there killing it man love to
see that thing grow doing its thing shot
again Midway monster does it steam deck
have a power chord yes has a power core
but I highly advise you get a power
brick that could support it if you can't
plug something in on the plate just just
to hit you though anyway oh shout out
for speculation up in there a lot of
people up in there today we've seen coal
a lot of people salute but yeah for me
you already know the deal um yeah I'll
be back he's only kidding only three
away from 10K make sure y'all follow
King David on Twitter so they can follow
you King David OTW kick Dave at King
David OTW get him a 10K that helps you
know what I'm saying you know what I'm
saying helps my man helps everybody and
uh yeah for us you already know three
away he's close you know salute
everybody pull up in the chat yo big
nice little surprise coming up next week
look for it we should I'm looking
forward to the guest next week should be
fun and uh yeah that's pretty much all
it is is it sad I have no idea what
you're talking about yeah I know look at
the guest list so check that out it
should be fun oh yeah yeah finally yeah
yeah yeah it was 79 doesn't hit me up so
I'm sorry I haven't been responding to
you right now
he wanted me to tell you guys there was
a fire show oh thank you you guys
definitely absolutely and also shout out
to the love y'all gave us for the Jason
Rubin interview I'm noticing that's
making the rounds a lot of people love
that twice yes like I watched it a few
times too I was like yeah that was one
of our better ones we've had a lot of
great interviews and no respect but yeah
that it felt good yeah love his energy
and it feels good to get the
acknowledgment when we all when we all
put it away you know how infectious he
is is when he even infected at it yes I
mean I was watching it was a couple of
times I had to go back and I was like
Wow addict engagement level yeah with
him was so high and and the Gap in age
and and generational was a lesson by the
fact that he was giving him nuggets to
actually be engaging with him it was so
dope he is such a good leader of men yes
yes that that I understand why he's so
highly successful and the behind the
scenes and publicly from other industry
people hitting me up uh shout out to
John lennerman shout out to digital
Foundry shout out to Giuseppe on vario
from um Splash damage who did gist hat a
lot of people behind the scenes were
like yo Bill still a lot of people like
yo that was a fantastic interview so
salute to us we did that and salute to
Jason Rubin he did that so if you ever
watched it go check that out and we're
gonna have more uh fun stuff played for
y'all so let's uh
get these super chats and get up on out
of here so we can enjoy our Sundays like
everybody else
uh oh what's up oh one minute oh so I'm
gonna install this off so um yeah so
we're starting for solve right now but
yeah salute to everybody who bought
those you know the stop stitching
movement Joyce is crazy salute to y'all
support that and make sure yo nobody I
want to see some show me your build
shirts man attic out here Smith premium
PC bars you know I want to see somebody
pick up one of them show me your Bells
before the show and that'd be kind of
cool ready to run ready I was ready to
rock you know what I'm saying but anyway
five dollars so this indie game gets a
full topic but I can't get y'all to even
mention Game of the Year contenders like
Xenoblade 3 and Kirby shaking my damn
I mean Super chat we'll talk about them
I mean none of us have I I haven't
played Dental blade
well Sovereign definitely ditched y'all
uh and and Cog yeah
and my switch hasn't been turned on
longer than my PlayStation so wow so
right now my switch just sits there as
an ornament like on a call just looking
at me and my PlayStation is the car so
both of them has been turned off and
they're just sitting there looking at me
while the Xbox is running and having fun
yo what you mean
p1553d wait y'all didn't do a stop
stitches yes we did it's up there
go to the store right there put the link
in [ __ ] man we got the stuff we got the
slides we got this everything we got the
stop stitching we got all that we got
that new church
in there go check it out in the shirt
section like on page three page four of
the shirt go check that out man they all
up in there anyway I guess yeah so I
play Kirby but I didn't finish it yet
but it's awesome but it's sorry
then we got EG Kenta five dollar Super
Chat Laura's the one thing I have not
heard people talking about is
hypothetically what will happen to ABK
if this deal does not happen and fail if
the deal doesn't go through then they
have to figure out their own mess on
their own right and I think there's
going to be Mutiny in the street and
blood in the street
yeah all right you're not listening to
that that's negative
it's not even that I honestly feel like
the pettiness in Xbox you don't want to
see that do not go through yeah because
then they're gonna feel like they had to
spend that money somewhere because of
inflation if that happens it let me me
tell you something and I'm gonna tell
you right now
if Sony snitching if Sony snitching
messes this deal up
if Sony out here ratting
messes this deal up
there's gonna be blood in your snow
[Laughter]
and let me tell you something
it's gonna be the worst hostile takeover
if you've ever seen in your life because
they're going to go over to just the
same way Sony wife the house Marque when
it was running him out talking about it
ain't our game is the console doing this
bricking and bothering stuff and we we
ship good games and they they brought
them and shut them up and put them in
the corner
on God and Me
because we both gonna be standing right
out there and I'm gonna have the
bullhorn It's Gonna be Me God Phil and
the rest of the team we're gonna be out
y'all gonna get purchased the whole
building
everything gonna get purchased we're
gonna shut y'all down we're gonna put
you on the Shelf it ain't gonna be no
PlayStation [ __ ] ain't gonna be like and
we just gonna take all your games and
your game's gonna come over if y'all
don't if they're snitching
by any way messes up this deal
and you know we we can mark the data
snitching happy
if from this Brazilian leak
you guys mess up our situation we gonna
buy you
and that's it because we want you yeah
and it's gonna be cheaper is y'all
cheaper than Activision like you're
people we gonna buy y'all for cheaper
and we're gonna we're gonna drop your
gains down to thirty dollars
[Laughter]
like difference two dollars of attack
King you don't want no smoke with that
Street Fighter 5 arcade edition
boy if I got it right there already
downloaded if you want if you if you
come for me and I didn't send for you
man I'll send you back packed up in a
box I will make you the box and you
don't want to be the Box
listen I have one dude called me out on
Street Fighter I beat his behind in
front of an audience live on PCX
do not ever call me out now hip hop game
is going to tell you I called our King
on Tekken I haven't played Tech in a
year
see a real American said he he did when
I smoked you in your gnarl too oh yeah
this is
tied up see the whole thing is you have
selective memory okay I worked you know
that I should come in your game pause
you shouldn't beat me in my game we
ain't gonna talk about it
it was the game that you chose I walked
up there and bloodied your nose it never
came into your section watch what I do
to you in that wrestling oh this is this
is the difference is I can call you out
in the game and I'm gonna rough you up
right I'm gonna rough you up you call me
out in your game and I put hands on you
yo let's do it over here
and that is me the whole match and he
was like how is this dude doing this
belief in myself so you call me on
Street Fighter I see you right after I
get out of this and I want you to post
the results think about this are you
done
you want some of this too old man
king would you like to play Halo
Saturday nights I don't think he's
calling you out though
a community game night with Halo be
happy to invite you any other Lord
interested here Saturday night is
Saturday that's tough yeah that's a
non-starter brother he's got to be
earlier on Saturday it's got to be like
earlier yeah no doubt just get dirty
looks for that
then we got Mr ordinary VX the IOP is a
therapy we need for the next week
got the attic show me your bill got into
that crispy blue they standing with
addicts on this and they count to show
me your mail addict all about that PC
masturbation wow
well they just bought it because I was
hating on PC are you good with that yeah
so keep hating every week off
obviously that wasn't changing
cool okay so that's it we're good oh no
no actually yeah I know now so look
everybody enjoy your Sunday next Sunday
will be another fun one and that's all I
got anything anybody else I got we good
new all right we out peace see y'all
next week
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]